Hallo und herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio mit der Nummer 302,
wo wir uns bei jeder Folge eines Themas annehmen und das so ein bisschen auseinanderbauen,
dann wieder zusammensetzen, sodass man es verstehen kann.
Oder wo man was vielleicht ganz Neues kennenlernt oder was kennenlernt,
wo man den Namen schon mal gehört hat und so denkt, ja, aber so richtig genau
weiß ich eigentlich auch nicht. Und das passiert heute, zumindest für mich.
Wir sprechen nämlich heute über eine, ich sag jetzt mal, netzpolitische Organisation
und ich will erst mal Konstanze Kurz begrüßen, Dr.
Konstanze Kurz, glaube ich, sie heute um hochoffizielle Vorstellungen gebeten hatte.
Deswegen herzlich willkommen, auch in dieser Folge, Dr. Konstanze Kurz.
Schön, dass Sie uns wieder beehren.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum du das jetzt so betonst, aber ich freue mich ganz
doll hier zu sein und über diesen speziellen netzpolitischen Verein,
über dessen Namen du noch nicht gesagt hast, zu sprechen, weil ich mich dem sehr verbunden fühle.
Genau, wir sprechen ja aus einem Anlass, nämlich eines Jubiläums des 50-Jährigen
genau und es geht um Epicenter Works und was das ist und was es genau macht,
das werden wir heute noch genau auseinandernehmen.
Aber Konz, ich wollte dich erstmal fragen, ich habe sozusagen nach so einem
Vergleich gesucht, also sozusagen das ist das österreichische Pendant zu in
Deutschland und dann ist mir nichts so richtig eingefallen, da bin ich drauf
gekommen, in Deutschland ist,
was so digitalpolitische Vereine angeht, gibt es nicht den einen,
sondern es gibt so verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen, könnte man fast sagen.
Es gibt so also den CCC und vielleicht könnte man im weitesten Sinne auch Digital
Courage dazuzählen, die sozusagen, sagen wir mal, die Datenschutzextreme und
auch andere extreme Forderungen immer verbringen.
Ja, D64, genau.
Genau, D64, dann eher so parteinah, sowas wie Algorithm March,
die sozusagen wirklich für den politischen Betrieb auch gemacht worden sind.
Aber das heißt, du hättest jetzt auch nicht sozusagen eine Einwortbeschreibung,
Epicenter Works ist wie?
Ne, und ich glaube auch, und da werden wir bestimmt auch drüber sprechen,
dass in Österreich die netzpolitischen Debatten ein bisschen anders gestrickt sind.
Und ich glaube auch nicht ganz so nah an diesen parteipolitischen Linien,
wie es mir hier so vorkommt. Das habe ich aber auch erst kürzlich gelernt.
Denn Epicenter feiert nicht etwa ein bestimmtes Jubiläum, sondern ein Jubiläumsjahr.
Also die wissen in Österreich nicht nur besser, netzpolitisch zu debattieren,
sondern die wissen auch besser zu feiern.
Okay, also wir machen heute so eine To-Do-Liste. Was man aus Österreich lernen
kann, ist anscheinend Feiern als erster Eintrag. Okay, gut.
Und dann begrüßen wir jetzt Tanja Fachertaler und Thomas Lohninger.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Danke, dass wir da sein dürfen.
Hallo, es freut mich.
Genau, der Sinn der heutigen Chaos-Radio-Folge ist ja so ein bisschen zu lernen,
wer oder was ihr seid. Und ich will, bevor wir am Anfang anfangen,
wie wir es immer machen, erst mal sozusagen euch die Gelegenheit geben,
so die Kurzvorstellung.
Irgendjemand hat mal zum Beispiel in einer Radiosendung, ich arbeite ja vor
dem Reitband auch, da war neulich jemand von euch zu Gast oder beziehungsweise
kam als Interview O-Ton in einem Beitrag vor.
Also jemand hat den Namen gehört und weiß so, ah, irgendwas mit Netzpolitik,
aber mehr nicht. Wer seid ihr? Wer oder was ist Epicenterworks?
Wir sind ein gemeinnütziger Verein mit Sitzern in Österreich,
in Wien. Uns gibt es seit 15 Jahren, deswegen auch das Jubiläum.
Und wir waren mal der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdaten und hatten das einziges Ziel,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung abzuschaffen.
Was wir 2014 aber geschafft haben in Österreich und auch mit unserer EuGH-Klage.
Ja und es gibt uns seitdem weiterhin und wir haben nur immer mehr Arbeit und
immer mehr Themen seitdem.
Und freuen uns unheimlich hier sein zu können. Also ich wäre auch nicht in der
Netzpolitik ohne Chaos Radio.
Ihr wart mal meine Einstiegsdroge, über die ich herausgefunden habe,
dass es all das gibt und sowas wie Hacker und Hackerspaces.
Und das war der Beginn für mich.
Deswegen schließt sich hier gerade ein persönlicher Kreis, dass wir heute hier sein dürfen.
Brauchen wir vielleicht bald so einen Beipackzettel für Risiken und Nebenwirkungen?
Fragen Sie Ihren Parteipolitiker?
Okay, also das begann als Widerstand, nee, stopp, ich wollte ja,
bevor wir in die Vergangenheit gehen, erst nochmal hier so ein bisschen fragen.
Also ein netzpolitischer Verein, was heißt denn das?
Also was macht ihr denn? Macht ihr sozusagen Kampagnen, verteilt Sticker und organisiert Demos?
All of the above. Also wir sind sehr nah an der Gesetzgebung.
Fast alles, was wir tun, hat unmittelbar etwas mit laufenden Gesetzgebungsverfahren zu tun.
Das ist sicherlich jetzt mal so 70, 80 Prozent unserer Arbeit.
Das heißt, wir schreiben juristische Stellungnahmen mit unserem Team von neun
MitarbeiterInnen, die wir da in Wien haben. tun das zur Hälfte in Österreich,
zur anderen Hälfte auf EU- und UN-Ebene.
Wir klagen auch aktuell zum Beispiel gegen die Deutsche Telekom,
aber auch manchmal in Kolumbien beim Verfassungsgerichtshof,
gegen Zero-Rating oder auch beim EuGH.
Wir machen Kampagnen online, aber auch offline.
Und wir machen auch Prozessbeobachtungen, wie im Fall von Julian Hessenthaler, dem Ibiza-Regisseur.
Es ist relativ breit und Österreich ist klein, Deswegen gibt es,
es gibt ein paar andere coole netzpolitische Vereine außer uns auch,
aber wir haben ein relativ breites Spektrum, das wir versuchen abzudecken,
so gut es uns halt möglich ist.
Also du, wenn du schon sozusagen so lange KS Radio hörst, kennst du ja die Regel,
wer in Frankfurt sagt, muss es erklären, was ist die EU-Rating?
Ach, das weiß doch jeder. Also Netzneutralität ist auch ganz eng verbunden mit unserem Verein.
Wir arbeiten an diesem obskuren Thema, wo es um offene und neutrale Netze geht, schon sehr lang.
Und Zero-Rating ist eine Form, wie Netzseutralität verletzt werden kann,
indem nämlich manche Daten billiger oder teurer sind als andere.
StreamOn, der Deutschen Telekom, war ein in Deutschland sehr populärer Ableger
von dieser Netzseutralitätsverletzung und da durften wir 2017 auch bei der Telekom
Hauptversammlung sagen, dass das illegal ist.
Telekom hat es nicht geglaubt. 2021 hat dann der Europäische Gerichtshof uns
Recht gegeben, dass es illegal ist.
Und Zero-Rating ist seitdem in Europa Geschichte.
Aber leider steht uns ja noch eine große Netzneutralitätsreform im Dezember diesen Jahres bevor.
Wie immer in der Netzpolitik, man vertagt die Themen nur. Wirklich gewonnen,
für immer sind sie nicht.
Ja, das ist leider wirklich so ein Learning von vielen netzpolitischen Debatten.
Aber Zero-Rating ist denn das Positive oder ist das Negative?
Ich dachte, Zero-Rating ist halt, der Datenverkehr wird nicht geratet oder wofür steht das?
Es ist schon so, dass es für die Endkunden dann so aussieht.
Nein, nein, also das konkrete Wort, Zero Rating, was meint das konkret?
Dass du eben gewisse Datenvolumina, also applikationsspezifisch zum Beispiel,
ganz oft ist bei Zero Rating es der Fall, dass alle Dienste von Meta geserorated sind.
Das heißt, du hast vielleicht sonst gar kein Datenvolumen, weil du es dir nicht
leisten kannst, aber du hast unendlich viel WhatsApp oder Instagram oder Facebook.
Das ist auch wirklich so. Die Konzerne, die am meisten profitiert von Zero Rating, ist Meta.
Ich habe ja vorher erwähnt, wir waren in Kolumbien beim Höchstgericht,
weil da war es auch so, dass Millionen Menschen im Land haben den Großteil des
Monats über gar kein Datenvolumen, aber sie haben unendlich viel WhatsApp.
Also das Zero steht für, dir wird nichts berechnet?
Ganz genau. Ah, verstehe. Okay, jetzt hat man schon sozusagen ein bisschen den
Eindruck, ihr kennt euch A aus, das war jetzt schon eine Stichprobe,
und B, ihr seid auch relativ hochrangig dran.
Das habe ich richtig verstanden. Also wenn ihr sagt, ihr arbeitet zu Gesetzen,
heißt das sozusagen, ihr arbeitet auch in Gremien mit oder seid in Kontakt mit
Politikern, in denen diese Gesetze beschließen?
Oder ist das eher so ein von außen daran arbeiten?
Also irgendjemand beschließt was und dann muss man Dinge anzünden, weil alles schlimm ist?
Wir würden das Anzünden nie ausschließen. Das ist durchaus Teil des Repertoires.
Aber unser erster Schritt ist immer mal aufzuschreiben, was der Sachstand ist
und wo das Problem ist. Das ist auch der spannendste Teil des Jobs.
Es kommt ein neues Gesetz und du musst dir eine Meinung herausbilden dazu.
Das ist bei uns immer faktenbasiert. Es muss technisch, rechtlich,
wissenschaftlich alles fundiert sein.
Und dann ist die zweite Anforderung, es muss lösungsorientiert sein.
Du darfst nur dagegen sein, wenn du weißt, wie es besser ginge.
Und das dritte ist eigentlich das Grundprinzip, wir sind unabhängig von allen
Parteien, Ideologien und Firmen.
Und das heißt dann konkret zum Beispiel Tanja, meine Kollegin,
ist dann in der UNO, wenn die Cybercrime Convention verhandelt wird,
die Person, die dort die Fackel in der Hand hat und auf die Gefahren dieser
UN-Konvention hinweist.
Dazu war sie ja auch schon mal im Chaos Radio zu Gast und das ist Arbeit,
die wir in Gremien machen, auch in den Medien machen und wenn gar nichts hilft,
gehen wir halt mit Kampagnen oder zum Höchstgericht an die Öffentlichkeit.
So, Tanja, dann würde ich von dir jetzt gerne wissen, also wenn du für die UN
Dinge machst, wie kommt man denn, bevor wir das für den Verein beschreiben,
von als Person sozusagen davon, dass man sich für das Thema interessiert und dann auf einmal...
In der UN berät oder eine Stimme hat für solche Verfahren?
Ja, das war tatsächlich ganz interessant, weil wir in Wien ja einen UN-Hauptsitz auch haben.
Aber interessanterweise bis vor wenigen Jahren gar nicht dort,
also in diesem Bereich tätig waren.
Und wir dann von Organisationen, international aktiven Organisationen,
NGOs angesprochen wurden, ob wir denn nicht bei dem Thema Cybercrime Convention mitarbeiten möchten.
Sie bräuchten eine Organisation, die in Wien ansässig wäre und es würde sich
doch toll mit unseren Arbeitsthemen decken.
Und ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, es war unheimlich interessant,
hat mich persönlich auch wahnsinnig gepackt, muss ich sagen.
Und so hat es begonnen und wir waren zuerst, wir sind nach wie vor sehr aktiv,
muss ich sagen, als so eine lose Vereinigung von internationalen NGOs,
die sich des Themas annehmen, die auf dieser Ebene auch sehr viel gearbeitet
haben und das nach wie vor auch tun.
Aber ja, so hat es im Wesentlichen begonnen und so hat eins zum anderen dann
auch geführt, also mit wiederholter Tätigkeit, wiederholten Anwesenheiten in
Wien, dann eben auch New York, Möglichkeiten zu intervenieren.
Ich war dann auch ein paar Mal bei Pressekonferenzen oder bei Side-Events,
also so Nebenveranstaltungen bei der UN in New York,
als Rednerin eingeladen und irgendwie war das ein Beginn, der mich persönlich
sehr interessiert hat, der auch sehr gut in unser Repertoire gepasst hat als
Verein und sich da ein Stück weit ausgedehnt hat.
Und ja, irgendwie sind wir da immer tiefer hineingeraten und das war eine tolle Erfahrung.
Also das heißt, man muss zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort sein,
in diesem Fall ein netzpolitischer Verein in Wien.
Genau. Und dann wird man gesehen und dann ergibt sich so eine Art Netzwerk.
Aber jetzt hat ja Thomas erzählt, er hat Chaos gerade gehört und dann ist alles
fürchterlich eskaliert. Wie bist du denn überhaupt zu dem Thema gekommen?
Ich bin vom Hintergrund ein bisschen anders aufgestellt. Ich bin Juristin.
Überhaupt nicht aus der Technik-Ecke kommen, sondern aus der Grund- und Menschenrechts-Ecke,
wenn man das so nennen kann.
Und habe da einiges an Erfahrung auch aus Brüssel mitgebracht.
Ich war mehrere Jahre für NGOs in Brüssel tätig, kenne den Betrieb dort ganz
gut, habe dann in Österreich selbst für eine Anwaltskanzlei gearbeitet eine Zeit lang.
Und dann festgestellt, dass ich eigentlich doch sehr gerne wieder in den zivilgesellschaftlichen
Bereich zurückkehren möchte und habe eine Ausschreibung von E-Center Works gesehen
und kannte die Organisation natürlich und habe mich auf diese Stelle beworben.
Es war tatsächlich eine Stelle für eine Juristin mit dem Bereich Grundrechte,
Verfassungsrecht und eben auch europarechtlichen Schwerpunkt.
Und so bin ich dazugekommen.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt aber mal tatsächlich zu dem Verein selber kommen.
Und das stelle ich erst mal vor, als so eine Menge von Leuten findet sich aus
der Not gedrungen zusammen und organisiert dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
vielleicht irgendwie Freiheit statt Angst Demos, wie es die in Deutschland gab.
Also macht Dinge und ist erst mal eine Gruppe von Leuten und nichts mehr.
Und was ich jetzt höre ist, es heißt zwar Verein,
es klingt zwar aber wie eine professionell arbeitende Firma,
ist jetzt das falsche Wort, das klingt nicht immer gleich so böse kapitalistisch,
aber es ist halt eben mehr als ein loser Zusammenschluss von Leuten,
sondern es ist halt was, wo es um Budgets geht, was Leute fest anstellen kann,
die Experten haben und was eben
sozusagen auf dieser internationalen und politischen Bühne auch arbeitet.
Könnt ihr vielleicht so diese Entwicklung, ich weiß 15 Jahre kann man wahrscheinlich
ewig drüber reden, aber könnt ihr diese Entwicklung skizzieren, wie das passiert ist?
Oder ist das eine Aneinanderreihung von wir waren in Wien und dann hat uns jemand gefragt und zack?
Nein, es war schon eine Absicht dabei, aber eben zuerst wirklich war der AK
Vorrat gedacht als Dachverband,
der sich einzig dem Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung widmet und auch in den ersten
Jahren alleinig durch ehrenamtliche Arbeit getragen.
Und wir haben zuerst mal irgendwie versucht, im Gesetzgebungsprozess uns einzubringen,
dann eine Bürgerinneninitiative, also eine Petition in Österreich beim Parlament zu machen.
Und die war unheimlich erfolgreich. Das war die größte Petition.
Die es bis damals in Österreich gab im Parlament.
Und dann eben auch mit der Verfassungsklage, das war so der letzte Streich,
mit dem wir versucht haben, dann unsere Argumente beim Höchstgericht anzubringen.
Und dort haben wir wirklich auch Gehör gefunden und da war dann auch klar,
dass es eine gute Kombination ist, die wir gefunden haben, weil das war auch
ein sehr diverses Team von Juristinnen, TechnikerInnen,
KünstlerInnen, die sich da zusammengefunden haben.
Und 2014, als wir Vorratsdatenspeicherung abgeschafft haben,
war dieser Übergang, wo wir gesagt haben, okay,
jetzt probieren wir dieses Thema ein bisschen auch ernsthafter zu behandeln
und auch mit bezahlter Arbeit und nicht mehr nur ehrenamtlich.
Ja, Netzpolitik ist zu wichtig, um nur ein Hobby zu sein für die Menschen.
Das war ja auch das Jahr eins nach Snowden. Das hat sicherlich auch mitgespielt.
Und ich habe persönlich damals, bin gerade von Brüssel zurückgekommen,
ich habe damals für EDRI an dem Netzentralitätsgesetz der EU gearbeitet.
Ganz kurz, EDRI, EU-Organisation, quasi eine Dach- und Versammlungsorganisation
für netzpolitische Institutionen aus ganz Europa.
Ganz genau. Und da durfte ich persönlich auch irgendwie das Lobbying-Handwerk
lernen und habe das auch so ein bisschen mitgebracht in das,
was wir dann im Verein in Österreich gemacht haben.
Und wir haben 2014 angefangen mit 3.000 Euro am Konto und ein paar guten Ideen
und sind dann aber doch sehr stark gewachsen und haben ein Team Stück für Stück aufbauen können.
Von Anfang an war das Ganze sehr stark getragen von Fördermitgliedern und Spenden,
aber immer auch ein bisschen Stiftungsgeld, weil es nur mit Spenden alleine
leider noch nicht funktionieren würde.
Und wir haben dann einfach versucht, mit dem Thema mitzuwachsen.
Am Anfang war das Ganze auch wirklich eher Nische und noch näher unbekannt.
Wir mussten mit großen kreativen Medienaktionen irgendwie schauen,
dass wir vorkommen in der öffentlichen Debatte.
Wir haben zum Beispiel damals eine Kamera attrappete mit Heliumluftballons an
der Pallas Athene-Statue vom Parlament festgemacht.
Die war 20 Minuten dort, aber das Foto war so cool, Das war dann auch an jeder
Tageszeitung in Österreich und auf einmal...
Das hat sogar nach Deutschland geschafft. Also manche Aktionen wurden dann auch hier berichtet.
Also ganz am Anfang war wirklich auch viel kreativer Wahnsinn dabei,
um überhaupt vorzukommen mit diesem neuen Thema Netzpolitik in Österreich.
Österreich ist da auch sicherlich um einiges später dran als Deutschland.
Wir haben diese Debatten in der Breite sicherlich nicht so gehabt vor 2010,
11, 12, 13. Das ist alles erst später passiert.
Und inzwischen ist es aber so, dass wir relativ gesetzt sind und halt auch als
fast nicht mehr sein kann, wenn die Politik irgendwas tut, läutet bei uns im
nächsten Moment das Telefon und die Medien fragen, was wir davon halten.
Und das ist auch natürlich eine enorme Verantwortung, die man hat als Verein.
Und wir sagen auch immer, es ist bei uns so, wie wenn du zum Arzt gehst,
du kriegst eine neutrale Diagnose für dein Gesetz.
Und wir versuchen da auch, dieser Ansprechpartner zu sein. Wir haben auch so
ein bisschen die Rolle, wie der Chaos Computer Club, dass manchmal auch Sicherheitslücken
an uns gemeldet werden und wir dann das an staatliche Stellen oder an die Medien weitergeben.
Natürlich immer Responsible Disclosure.
Und ja, ein bisschen sind wir Mädchen für alles.
Also Responsible Disclosure.
Ich würde mal ganz kurz, ich würde mal gerne nur noch für die zeitliche Dimension so eine gewisse, ja.
Wenn du das jetzt machst, dann musst du Responsible Disclosure ganz kurz erklären
und darauf verweisen, dass wir eine Chaos Folge dazu haben.
Okay, nee, dann frag lieber nach. Entschuldigung.
Ich wollte nur kurz gesagt haben, Responsible Disclosure ist eine Art und Weise,
Sicherheitslücken so zu melden, dass sie a.
Nicht unterschlagen werden können, aber b. auch nicht größtmöglichen Schaden
anrichten. Und dazu haben wir eine eigene Folge, die wir in den Show Notes verlinken. Korns.
Ich würde eigentlich nur gerne noch kurz eine Parallele zu Deutschland ziehen,
denn auch hier war ja die ganze Debatte,
Und die sich über Jahre zog, über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung für viele netzpolitische
Aktivisten, so eine Art Starting Point.
Also bei uns war ja das Urteil, das war ja schon aus dem Jahr 2010,
als vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, war ja sozusagen das Ende von der ganzen Bewegung,
die sich hier gebildet hat, gegen technische Überwachung und eben speziell Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also es gibt eine gewisse Parallele, finde ich, zu der deutschen Entwicklung.
Die war ein bisschen früher, weil ja das Urteil dann, also was ihr erkämpft
habt, auch vom Europäischen Gerichtshof, da sind ja noch ein paar Jahre dazwischen.
Aber ich glaube, das Thema hat eben nicht nur in Österreich,
sondern auch in Deutschland viel Aktivismus, der sich einfach dann über die
Jahre weiterentwickelt hat, so ein bisschen, hat gestartet damit.
Das ist zumindest mein Eindruck.
Ich muss jetzt mal eine inhaltliche Nachfrage stellen, weil mir stellen sich
immer so ein bisschen die Nackenhaare auf, wenn gesagt wird,
etwas sei neutral und parteiübergreifend, weil das heute in den Zeiten oft bedeutet,
man glaubt, die eigene Position sei objektiv, was in politischen Diskussionen oft nicht stimmt.
Und also das, ich tut mir leid, aber es sind meine Assoziationen,
die die Zeiten in mir schaffen.
Wenn jemand sagt, Parteien umabhängig, ist das oft sozusagen nach rechts außen offen.
Was ich euch nicht vorwerfe, ich frage mich nur sozusagen, was genau meint ihr
oder meinst du, Thomas, mit dieser Betonung des Neutralen und Unabhängigen,
weil das kann es ja eigentlich nicht geben und
also um es sozusagen ganz platt und banal zu sagen,
ihr werdet sicherlich vielleicht nicht nicht im Chaos Radio,
aber auf eine andere Art und Weise im Chaos Radio, wenn es nicht eine bestimmte
Schlagrichtung dessen gäbe, was ihr machen würdet?
Absolut. Also es gibt, du kannst uns natürlich unterstellen,
wenn das falsche Wort, aber ich glaube, Netzpolitik hat schon eine gewisse Ideologie.
Erkommt, man hat das jetzt in der Hackerethik verortet oder in dieser Perspektive,
kritisch gegenüber über staatlichen Handeln, multinationalen Konzernen und dem
Status Quo in vielerlei Dingen zu sein.
Ich glaube aber, wie wir Neutralität verstehen bedeutet, dass wir jede Partei kritisieren,
Und gleichzeitig aber auch Lob aussprechen, wenn irgendjemand etwas richtig macht.
Das ist teilweise dann auch verstörend. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch das Innenministerium
mal gelobt, weil Volkszählungen gibt es in Österreich nicht mehr.
Das basiert jetzt auf Knopfdruck.
Also man bedient sich bestehender staatlicher Register, um den Zensus zu erheben.
Und da kann man natürlich auch viel falsch machen.
Aber hier wurde alles richtig gemacht. Wir haben da eine Analyse geschrieben,
dass das Innenministerium aus Datenschutz-Sicht alles richtig gemacht hat.
War für uns neu, war für das Innenministerium neu.
Und genauso verstehen wir das halt auch.
Also wir haben natürlich jetzt als Menschenrechtsorganisation eine Grundhaltung
und auch wenn wir dann zum Beispiel kooperieren.
Wir haben jetzt seit wenigen Tagen in Österreich ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz
und das Erste, wo wir jetzt genau mit einer großen Anfrageserie mal gefragt
haben, ist der Asyl- und Sozialbereich in Österreich,
weil wir starke Vermutungen gemeinsam mit einer Schwesterorganisation haben,
dass dort KI eingesetzt wird.
Und wir versuchen da schon sehr bewusst auch unsere Expertise auch zusammen
mit anderen Akteuren einzubringen in den Debatten, wo es brennt.
Und Menschenrechte werden immer bei jenen eingeschränkt, die keine starke Stimme
in der Gesellschaft haben.
Das ist auch ein Auftrag, den wir verstehen.
Aber gleichzeitig, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Upload-Filter im Europaparlament
verhindern will, dann sind wir auch die Organisation, die ganz klar sagt,
ja, es geht um jede Stimme.
Und wenn man dazu auch mit den Rechten sprechen muss, dann tun wir das auch
als österreichische Organisation.
Wir kommen da ja auch nicht aus. Die sind bei uns seit Jahrzehnten in der Regierung.
Und wir haben da auch die Grundhaltung, dass wir mit allen im Parlament vertretenen Parteien sprechen.
Das ist auch etwas, das bei uns schon von Anfang an und eigentlich auch bei
allen Vorgängerorganisationen von unserer in Österreich der Status quo ist.
Dass man sich zwar die Nase zuhält, aber durchaus dann auch mit denen schaut,
dass man sachpolitisch zusammenarbeiten kann.
Kranz, könntest du das für Deutschland und die AfD auch vorstellen?
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, jetzt aus Sicht des CCC und auch so,
wenn ich auf die deutschen netzpolitischen Vereine gucke, eher nicht.
Aber ich war ja in einer dieser Kampagnen von Epicenter mal beteiligt vor ein paar Jahren.
Da ging es um den Staatsräume und bin ja auch nach Wien gefahren,
so um Expertise beizutragen.
Ich habe natürlich gelernt, dass dort die parteipolitischen Debatten wirklich
anders ablaufen und dass es auch fluider ist.
So wer da mit wem, in welchen Themen arbeitet. Ich fand das auch ein bisschen überraschend.
Aber man muss, glaube ich, lernen, dass Debatten anders funktionieren.
Und die Deutschen ja sowieso bei rechten Parteien sehr viel stärker so Abgrenzungstendenzen haben.
Die würde ich in Deutschland auch auf jeden Fall sehen für die allermeisten
netzpolitischen Vereine und so Aktivisten.
Ich kann aber verstehen, dass es in Österreich anders ist. Und ich habe viel
gelernt, wie unterschiedlich die Länder politisch funktionieren.
Ich kann es mir für Deutschland trotzdem nicht vorstellen.
Aber habt ihr... Tanja, ja gerne.
Es gab in der Vergangenheit bei uns sogar mal eine Kooperation mit der FPÖ,
also mit der Rechtsrechtenpartei und den Grünen.
Also auch so kann es aussehen im Alltag bei uns.
Ich verlasse diese Strecke gleich wieder. Ich bin nur sozusagen gleichermaßen
perplex als auch interessiert.
Wenn man solche Akteure in den politischen, sei es auch nur netzpolitischen,
also nur in Anführungszeichen netzpolitischen Diskurs einbindet,
das führt ja zu nachhaltigen Normalisierungen.
Also man sagt, weil die im Parlament sind, sind sie also gleichrangige Gesprächspartner
zu allen anderen Parteien.
Macht euch das Kopf zerbrechen oder das ist für euch einfach so?
Da muss man halt die unterschiedliche Historie sehen. Also in Österreich ist
die FPÖ seit Jahrzehnten in Regierungsverantwortung, immer wieder mal on und off.
Und die meisten Male endet das in großen Korruptionsskandalen und sie sind danach
wieder zu Recht außerhalb von einem Machtspektrum.
Aber wenn es vor allem eben um das Verhindern von gefährlichen Gesetzen und
ganz oft Kompetenzen für das Innenministerium geht,
ja dann gehen wir mit den Sozialdemokraten und den Liberalen zum Höchstgericht,
genauso wie mit den Grünen und mit der FPÖ.
Also das ist alles schon passiert in unserer Historie. Und wir haben auch teilweise
wortgleiche Forderungen von uns in den Wahlprogrammen von eigentlich allen Parteien,
mit Ausnahme der Konservativen, aber die schreiben auch von uns ab.
Und das ist auch etwas, wo wir mit Creative Commons Lizenz auch kein Problem damit haben.
Wir würden niemals nur dieser einen Partei hier irgendwie eine Bühne liefern.
Aber wenn es um Kooperationen geht, wo sozusagen ein Drittel der Abgeordneten
notwendig ist, um ein Gesetz überhaupt zum Höchstgericht zu bringen,
in Österreich geht das vor allem bei verdeckten Ermittlungsmethoden halt einfach
nicht anders, dann wäre das etwas, das wir tun würden.
Und ich glaube auch, dass da letzter Punkt im Europaparlament ist,
nochmal viel spannender ist.
Im Moment, wo wir halt auch eine Gemengelage haben, wo dieses Wir reden nicht
mit den Rechten bedeutet, es ist halt fast mathematisch ausgeschlossen,
noch eine Mehrheit hinzubekommen.
Gerade wenn die EU-Kommission mit der Europäischen Volkspartei in Lockstep bei einigen Sachen agiert.
Und wir haben halt einfach die Aufweichung von Netzneutralität,
Datentrittsgrundverordnung, AI Act und ganz vielen Kernbestandteilen der netzpolitischen
Regulierung jetzt gerade im Arbeitsprogramm der EU-Kommission.
Also wenn man da jetzt sagt, wir müssen aber ideologisch hier eine Linie ziehen.
Erstens, in vielen Ländern ist das total muddy. In manchen Ländern sind die
Sozialdemokraten weitaus rassistischer und faschistischer unterwegs als Parteien,
die man sonst vielleicht bei den Rechtsextremen einsortieren würde.
Wie in der Slowakei zum Beispiel, da muss man halt auch genauer hinschauen.
Das ist in der Realpolitik leider oft ein wirklich schmutzigeres Handwerk.
Habt ihr denn irgendeine Art von Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss? Also gibt es bis
für euch eine Grenze oder würdet ihr das sozusagen bis ins Extrem führen?
Also wir haben klare Gänzen, wie wir uns finanzieren. Wir haben auch absolute Transparenz.
Finanzierung wollen wir gleich reden. Ich meine, in der politischen Zusammenarbeit.
Also gäbe es für euch eine Grenze, wo ihr sagt, mit der Partei arbeiten wir nicht mehr zusammen.
Also weil das, was du jetzt sagst, klingt schon so, dass auch Parteien,
die menschenverachtende Inhalten in ihrem Programm haben, Partner sind,
wenn es sozusagen wegen der Stimmgewalt technisch gesehen sein muss.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel in der Pandemie ganz stark bei allen,
die nicht wissenschaftlich agieren.
Also da würden wir auch niemals uns sozusagen zu Projekten oder Themen äußern,
die einfach keine Faktenrelevanz haben.
Aber vor allem, das sind jetzt auch nicht so diese Dinge, wo du gemeinsam für
etwas bist, sondern eher es geht ums konkrete Verhindern von Vorschlägen,
die gemacht werden, von Gesetzesvorhaben, von Software- und IT-Projekten,
die schon aufgegleist sind, wo du versuchst, Schlimmeres zu verhindern.
Also das ist auch, worüber wir hier reden. Also das sind ja immer das Weglagen von Dingen.
Genau, das ist schon klar, aber die Frage ist halt sozusagen,
würdet ihr trotzdem immer mit einer politischen Partei, egal wie rechtsaußen
sie ist, da gemeinsame Sachen machen, wenn es um Zweckklagen geht?
Oder gäbe es für euch da irgendwo eine Grenze?
Im Inneren gibt es ganz viele harte Grenzen, wenn man uns als Verein kennt.
Und die Menschen dahinter ist das sehr, sehr klar.
Aber als Verein haben wir halt wirklich eine Rolle in Österreich,
wo wir halt wirklich eher so wie der Doktor sind, zu dem jeder gehen kann und
man kriegt eine neutrale Diagnose, egal wer es ist.
Und das ist auch sicherlich etwas, wo uns oft was abverlangt wird.
Aber es ist halt einfach notwendig, dieser Stimme zu sein und das gibt dir dann
aber auch natürlich ein enormes Gewicht, weil du sagen kannst,
hey, ich bin ja aber wirklich nur dem Thema und das ist in dem Fall die Grundrechte
im Digitalen verpflichtet.
Und nachdem alle von uns schon mal kritisiert und vielleicht manchmal auch gelobt
wurden, hat das dann halt auch einfach mehr Gewicht.
Ja, ich würde dabei agree to disagree bleiben, weil ich glaube sozusagen so
eine gewisse Normalisierung, also ich verstehe, dass ihr den sozusagen diesen
Teufelshandel macht und machen müsst eurer Ansicht nach oder wollt,
aber dass man halt trotzdem, indem man so vorgeht, dass zu einer Normalisierung
beiträgt, ist glaube ich nicht von der Hand zu weisen, auch wenn der Beitrag,
vielleicht könnte man argumentieren minimaler, aber ich glaube da ist er auf
jeden Fall. Aber weil du gerade angefangen hast...
Vielleicht wollen wir das mal kurz noch für diese europäische Ebene ansprechen.
Thomas hatte das eben gesagt. Ja.
Der Unterschied in diesen politischen Debatten besteht ja auch darin,
wer die tatsächliche Macht hat.
Das ist in Österreich halt auch schon länger mal eine Regierung,
die auch eine FPÖ-Beteiligung hatte. Und in Europa ist es jetzt auch so.
Und wenn wir sozusagen den Hintergrund angucken der Entstehung von Epicenter,
dann haben wir jetzt ja genau das Thema, nämlich die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
was jetzt aktuell wieder vorangetrieben wird.
Und jetzt guckt man sich das an, wie da jetzt die Mehrheitsverhältnisse in Europa sind.
Und da wird man nicht drum herum kommen, auch mit den Rechten zu reden.
Das geht schon sozusagen von den Mehrheitsverhältnissen nicht mehr.
Wir haben ja quasi einen Luxus in Deutschland, dass die weitgehend nicht mitregieren.
Die Frage ist, was passieren wird, wenn sie das hier tun. Also die Debatte ist
ja in Österreich nicht mehr theoretisch.
Und in Europa ist sie auch nicht mehr. Und ich frage mich halt,
wie man das jetzt machen soll.
Etwa wenn man Widerstand gegen die neue Initiative zur Vorratsentsprechung in
Europa organisieren will, ohne über den Rechten zu reden.
Das ist tatsächlich auch gerade für die deutsche netzpolitische Szene ein Problem,
weil in Europa das eben schlichtweg nicht mehr möglich ist.
Also weiß ich nicht, wie ihr auf der UN-Ebene ist, da ist ja sicherlich nochmal
was anderes, weil ja zum Beispiel in Tanjas Feld, da redest du ja in der Regel
mit Regierungen und versuchst, da irgendwie Fachkompetenz reinzubringen.
Aber da sind natürlich auf UN-Ebene Offenige dabei, die ziemlich weit rechts sind.
Das ist ja ein Problem, gerade so, wenn es um die größeren Entitäten geht.
Ja, das ist definitiv der Fall. Also auf UN-Ebene sind es dann eben meistens
Diplomaten oder im Fall der Cybercrime-Konvention waren es zum Teil auch Staatsanwälte
oder Richter, Richterinnen.
Inwieweit da jemand aus einer bestimmten politischen Ecke kommt,
ist dann oft schwer zu sagen für die konkrete Person.
Aber natürlich, ja, es gibt Tendenzen, die der jeweiligen staatlichen Politik natürlich nahestehen.
Und das kann man auch nicht von der Hand weisen. Natürlich gab es da für uns
auch Grenzen, einfach weil es mit gewissen Staaten sinnlos war zu sprechen.
Da war es ganz klar, dass die ihre eigene Agenda fahren.
Die Frage war halt dann wirklich, was man mit den Staaten zwischen,
ich sage jetzt mal, zwei Extremen oder eben zwei Polen macht und wie man damit
umgeht und wie mit denen gesprochen wird.
Und das ist dann natürlich etwas, was versucht wird.
Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das sind jetzt konkrete parteipolitische Tendenzen
oder parteipolitische Strömungen weniger klar,
weniger, sage ich jetzt mal, dominant, als es das wahrscheinlich im Europaparlament ist.
Ganz einfach, weil der Gesetzgebungs-Persatz auf UN-Ebene ganz anders funktioniert.
Jetzt haben wir schon sozusagen der Kampf vor der Zeitenspeicherung bei der
Anfang kommt jetzt bald wieder auf. Ganz kurz klang schon mal Ibiza an.
Vielleicht könnt ihr für allen, die nur noch grob in Erinnerung haben und weil
wir gerade auch von der FPÖ sprachen, nochmal kurz wiederholen,
was Ibiza war und was eure Rolle darin war.
Also sozusagen die netzpolitische Komponente des Ibiza-Skandals war mir noch nicht so ganz klar.
Ja, also das Ibiza-Video, das im Mai 2019 veröffentlicht wurde,
zeigte ja den damaligen FPÖ-Chef und zu dem Zeitpunkt auch Vizekanzler Österreichs,
Hans-Christian Strache,
mit einem Parteikollegen von ihm in einer Finca in Ibiza beim vermeintlichen
Gespräch mit einer russischen Oligarchin,
wo dann gleich über die Privatisierung des Wassers und Staatsaufträge verhandelt
wurde, wenn man nur den Boulevard mit der Kronenzeitung gefügig machen könnte.
Also sehr viel moralisch und rechtlich sehr zweifelhafte Diskussion,
die dann eben als dieses Video, das 2017 entstanden ist,
das ist 2019 veröffentlicht worden und hat dann zum Ende der konservativ-rechtsextremen
Regierung zwischen ÖVP und FPÖ geführt und zu Neuwahlen.
Und da war relativ schnell dann auch klar, wer dieses Video gemacht hat.
Das war eben Julian Hessenthaler und Ramin Mirfakai, ein Rechtsanwalt und ein
der Sicherheitsbranche aktiver Mensch.
Und da gab es in Österreich aber von vornherein unheimlich viele Gerenke darum,
okay, wer war das jetzt wirklich?
War es irgendeine andere Partei? War es ein Geheimdienst?
Und relativ spät ist dann halt eben so die komplette Story auch klar geworden,
weil die Leute, die es getan haben, dann auch da selber an die Öffentlichkeit getreten sind.
Ja und es war dann...
Ich würde nur der Vollständigkeit haben,
die russische Oligarchin war eine vermeintliche russische Oligarchin.
Genau, war nicht echt. Und ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Die Ermittlungen haben sich sehr stark dann fokussiert auf Julian Hessenthaler
und man hat wirklich so 95 Prozent aller Ressourcen nicht auf die Korruption,
die in diesem Video ja offensichtlich war,
verwendet, sondern um die Hintermänner dieses Videos ausfindig zu machen.
Und das Ganze hat dann auch zu einer Auslieferung von Julian von Deutschland
nach Österreich geführt und mit dieser Auslieferung hat eigentlich unsere Arbeit begonnen,
Weil Kolleginnen in Deutschland uns dann eben verbunden haben mit seinen Anwälten
und dadurch bekamen wir komplette Einsicht in den Ermittlungsakt.
Das waren 40.000 Seiten, die da produziert wurden mit allen möglichen Ermittlungsmaßnahmen,
die gesetzt wurden. Wir haben das durchgearbeitet.
Wir haben auch mehrere hundert Seiten davon anonymisiert, dass wir sie veröffentlichen konnten.
Und dann war für uns sehr klar, das ist eine politisch motivierte Strafverfolgung.
Sehr einseitig und auch mit massiven Überwachungsaufwendungen versucht einfach
nur diese Menschen auswendig zu machen,
die eigentlich, und das haben Gerichte in Deutschland, Österreich und Spanien
festgestellt, im Sinne des öffentlichen Interesses gehandelt haben.
Also ja, das war eine verdeckte Tonbildaufnahme unter solche Illegale in Deutschland,
Österreich, in Spanien nicht.
Aber in jedem Fall ist das zum überwiegenden öffentlichen Interesse.
Das war unser Befund, den zu äußern wäre aber tödlich gewesen für uns als Organisation,
weil wir sind zu klein, um uns sowas sagen zu tragen und deswegen haben wir
eine Koalition gezimmert von vielen anderen Organisationen, darunter auch die
Electronic Frontier Foundation, Article 19,
Whistleblower Organisationen und auch Amnesty International Österreich.
Und dann sind wir damit an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen, zum Prozessstart gegen Julian Hessenthaler.
Und bis dahin galt er als der vermeintliche Drogendealer, der im Zwielicht steht.
Und wir haben es da wirklich auch geschafft mit der Veröffentlichung und mit
dem Gerichtsverfahren, das wirklich meiner persönlichen Meinung nach ein Justizskandal
war, dass die Meinung sich auch sehr gedreht hat.
Und Tanja und ich waren auch bei, also Tanja war bei jeder einzelnen Verhandlung.
Ich war so gut es ging irgendwie vor Ort.
Wir haben natürlich Prozessbeobachtung gemacht und haben da halt eben auch versucht
aufzuzeigen, dass Rechtsstaatlichkeit hier auch bei diesen brisanten Fällen,
wo die Regierung gestürzt wurde, einzuhalten ist.
Man darf nicht ein Exempel statuieren aus Leuten, nur weil gewissen Teilen des
Sicherheitsapparats nicht gefällt, was die an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht haben.
Vielleicht sollte ich der Ergänzung selber auch noch sagen, es ging ja in dem
konkreten Verfahren gar nicht um dieses Video, sondern es ging um Vorwürfe der
Urkundenfälschung und eben auch des Drogenhandels.
Und das war tatsächlich höchst fragwürdig und hat sich, wie der Thomas auch
schon gesagt hat, auch in unseren Augen einfach nicht der stichhaltige Wesen.
Man hat tatsächlich versucht, über diese Schritte, wohl auch konstruierte Schritte,
also das ist unsere Auffassung, den Julian Hessenthaler einfach ausgeliefert
zu bekommen, weil man ihn ja strafrechtlich nicht belangen konnte wegen des Ibiza-Videos.
Das war aber genau genommen kein netzpolitischer Fall.
Das war ein politischer Fall, aber ihr macht also mehr als nur,
ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, reine Netzpolitik.
Ja, also in dem Fall tatsächlich, was uns besonders interessiert hat,
war einfach der große Überwachungsaufwand und die Mittel, die da eingesetzt
wurden, nämlich auch diverseste Bewegungen, die er in Europa gesetzt hat.
Also es ging hin, bis die Leihautos, diverse Handys wurden abgehört,
nicht nur seines, sondern von sämtlichen seiner Bezugspersonen.
Also es war ein, der tatsächlich gesetzt wurde europaweit, um seiner Habhaft zu werden.
Und das war etwas, wo wir hellhörig geworden sind und mal nachsehen wollten,
wie denn da tatsächlich vorgegangen wurde und wofür denn diese Schritte gesetzt wurden.
Und ja, es war jetzt nicht unbedingt ein klassisch-netzpolitisches Thema und
in dem Zusammenhang sicher etwas, wo wir uns auch ausgebreitet und ein bisschen verbreitet haben,
aber definitiv etwas, was wir in einem engen Zusammenhang gesehen haben mit
unserer Tätigkeit und uns daher entschlossen haben, auch hier tätig zu sein.
Und das ist, du hast schon recht, Markus.
Wir haben sicherlich jetzt gewissen Grundstock an Themen, wo wir immer aktiv
sein werden, wo wir jedes Gesetz analysieren und das auch immer dazu äußern.
Aber dadurch, dass wir den Luxus haben, dass wir viele Spenden bekommen,
können wir halt auch schnell reagieren.
Zum Beispiel auch als einer der bekanntesten und ältest dienenden Kabarettisten
im Land, Florian Schäuber,
vom Chef des Bundeskriminalamts angezeigt wurde, weil ihm ein Witz und eine
Kolumne nicht gefallen hat, sind wir auch tätig geworden und haben auch Prozessbeobachtung gemacht.
Also hin und wieder sind es auch wirklich so rechtsstaatliche Themen und Prinzipien
und Fair-Trial-Prinzipien, die uns auf den Plan rufen und am Ende funktioniert
Netzpolitik aber auch nicht, wenn man sich nicht auf den Rechtsstaat verlassen kann.
Jetzt haben wir Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Ibiza sind jetzt wirklich zwei Sachen,
die sind ja in Deutschland auch passiert und zwar nicht zu knapp.
Gibt es denn in eurer Geschichte auch sozusagen, also keine Ahnung,
für die Dramaturgie wäre jetzt fantastisch, es gibt eine Geschichte,
die war in Österreich riesig und für euch ein total großes Ding,
die man in Deutschland aber vielleicht gar nicht kennt.
Gute Frage. Also ich meine, es gab mehrere Datenskandale in Österreich,
die sehr groß waren, wo wir Systeme aufgedeckt haben.
Aber das hatte die auch in Deutschland. Das hat mal irgendwie so auf einen Schlag
fast alle Covid-Testergebnisse ungeschützt im Netz waren.
Oder die ganze Frage des Contact Tracings war ein riesiges Thema für uns.
Und gleichzeitig vieles dieser Dinge ist strukturgleich. In den letzten Monaten
war der Staatstrojaner, den wir in Österreich Bundestrojaner nennen.
So hieß er hier auch mal.
Ja, und das ist auch was, wo wir jetzt gerade den fünften Anlauf,
eine solche Software zu legalisieren, Jetzt gerade ist es sozusagen ein beschlossenes
Gesetz, das 2027 in Kraft treten soll.
Da schauen wir auch gerade, ob wir das noch beim Höchstgerecht zur Fall bekommen.
Und das sind aber Themen, die sind, glaube ich, alle auch in Deutschland bekannt.
Österreich ist nicht so anders.
Es gibt so ein bisschen eine zeitliche gewisse Latenz. Ihr habt die immer ein bisschen später.
Vielfach scheint mir aber, ihr seid erfolgreicher in der Abwehr.
Also gerade bei dem, was bei euch Bundestrojaner heißt und bei uns Staatstrojaner,
ist ja die gesetzliche Lage in Deutschland sehr viel schlechter in Bezug auf
die vielfachen Erlaubnisse, die Polizeibehörden und auch Geheimdienste haben.
Und ihr habt, glaube ich, was in der Abwehr oft erfolgreicher.
Wahlcomputer könnte man da noch nennen. Also es war ja immer so ein bisschen
nachgelagert, aber manchmal war auch die Diskussion bei euch,
fand ich zumindest, ein bisschen sachlicher. Ja, also nicht ganz so aufjährig, wie das oft bei uns ist.
Ja, so bei Bundestrojaner, Staatstrojaner,
wir haben die ersten vier Anläufe wirklich gut abwehren können und auch oft
wirklich mit Sachargumenten in der Begutachtung und eben auch schon einmal 2019 beim Höchstgericht.
Jetzt aktuell ist es leider beschlossen, aber eben nur für den nachrichtendienstlichen
Bereich, für den Inlandsgeheimdienst.
Gleichzeitig gab es das Versprechen der Regierung, keine weitere Ausweitung
von Staatstrojaner in dieser Legislaturperiode zu machen.
Und man hat gleich noch das Versprechen nachgelegt, es bleibt beim Nein zur
Chatkontrolle, dass Österreich ja im Moment aufrecht hat.
Und das reicht uns nicht, aber es ist zumindest schon mal irgendwie ein Zeichen, dass man,
auch wenn man gegen die netzpolitische Community agiert, da immer auch sich
bewusst ist, dass es hier Linien gibt und am Ende natürlich,
glaube ich, auch in der Bevölkerung eine Sensibilität bei diesem Thema,
nicht anders als in Deutschland auch,
die natürlich die Basis ist für alles, was wir tun.
Naja, wenn man es jetzt direkt vergleicht, ist das schon deutlich besser als
bei uns. Also ihr habt eine klare Positionierung der Regierung zur Chat-Kontrolle.
Wir haben immer noch eine unentschiedene Regierung.
Sag mal kurz, was Chat-Kontrolle ist.
Chat-Kontrolle ist ein EU-Vorhaben, also ein Plan der EU-Kommission,
die versucht in Nachrichteninhalte hineinzuschauen und zwar im Wege sozusagen
des sogenannten Client-Site-Scannings.
Man will also ran an die Clients, diejenigen Geräte, die Nachrichten übertragen,
weil man an verschlüsselte Kommunikation nicht anders ran kann.
Also es ist noch ein sehr umstrittet Vorhaben, schon lange, aber es kommt eben
darauf an, welche Regierungen in Europa welche Positionen einnehmen.
Nämlich deswegen, weil man eine Sperrminorität braucht, also eine gewisse Anzahl
von Ländern, die sich dagegen wendet, damit es nicht durchkommt.
Und in Österreich ist die Positionierung schon klar, Deutschland immer noch nicht.
Österreich hat keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. In Deutschland wird sie in ganz kurzer Zeit kommen.
Also es gibt schon Referenten an Vorhofer und es gibt auch eine Einigung zwischen
den beiden oder drei Regierungsparteien, CDU, CSU und SPD.
Wir haben hier klare Gesetze für Staatsrohianer, die alle Polizeien und Geheimdienste
mittlerweile einsetzen können und auch verschiedene Arten von Staatsrohianern.
Während die Österreicher gerade sozusagen jetzt erst im Juli das erste Mal überhaupt
eine Form von gesetzlicher Erlaubnis haben, wir sind da echt viel schlechter
aufgestellt, muss man einfach sagen.
Wie viel Palazin gibt es denn bei euch?
Oh ja, auch eine gute Frage.
Offiziell gar nicht. Es gibt auch immer wieder mal parlamentarische Anfragen
und eben jetzt seit 1. September haben wir ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
So weit voraus sind wir nicht in allen Themen. Und es gibt jetzt auch schon
am 4. September, wo wir aufrufen, schon die ersten IFG-Anfragen zu Palantir.
Aber im Moment ist bis auf einzelne Termine, wo Palantir mal Demos gemacht hat,
im Verteidigungs- und im Innenministerium noch keine Kooperation bekannt und
angeblich auch noch kein Geld geflossen.
Also zumindest nach dem, was wir wissen, hat Palantir seine Giftszene noch nicht
in Österreich versenkt.
Aber nachdem unser Ex-Kanzler Sebastian Kurz ja direkt nach seiner Kanzlerschaft
bei Peter Thiel in Thiel Invest angefangen hat zu arbeiten,
auch ehemalige Führungspersonen in der Sozialdemokratie für Palantir inzwischen arbeiten.
Ich glaube schon, dass das von Seiten Palantirs jetzt kein Interesse besteht,
aber vielleicht ist man da einfach noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Also noch kurz Palantir, eine
Naja, Polizeisoftware ist vielleicht ein bisschen kurz eine Software,
die man benutzen will, um alle möglichen Daten über Menschen zu sammeln,
Verbrecherdatenbanken, Ziele
für Anschläge, die regierungssanktioniert sind, also das Feld ist weit.
Das ist halt eine US-amerikanische Firma, wo halt Peter Thiel,
einer der Tech Bros, also der Tech Bro, könnte man fast sagen,
dahinter steckt, riesiges weites Feld.
Aber es ist in Deutschland gerade in der Diskussion, weil Palantir in manchen
Bundesländern schon im Einsatz ist und es zunehmend Bestrebungen gibt,
das auch bundesweit einzusetzen.
Das ist schon konkret. Der Dobrindt hat sich da ganz klar dafür ausgesprochen.
Und es gibt auch schon einen Referentenentwurf. Also in Deutschland ist es schon
Relativ weit, auch für die Bundespolizeien.
Und es ist halt sozusagen so ein klassisches Beispiel von,
in Deutschland mögen wir aus netzpolitischer Sicht vielleicht zwei Sachen nicht,
das ist Überwachung und zentralisierte Datenbanken und Palantir ist beides,
aber betrieben auf US-amerikanischer Infrastruktur.
Das ist quasi gerade sowas wie ein netzpolitischer Albtraum.
Anyways, zurück zu euch.
Konz hat ja gerade sozusagen so ein bisschen neidisch, habe ich es gehört,
gesagt, dass ihr in vielen Sachen eben sehr viel, also nicht nur bessere Positionen
erreicht habt im Sinne von dem, was so klassischer netzpolitischer Aktivismus will,
sondern dass es auch viel konsistenter ist, also nicht beim nächsten Husten umgeworfen wird.
Also gerade die Chatkontrolle, das ist ja in der EU gerade so,
alle halben Jahre wechselt die Ratspräsidentschaft und dann wird jedes Mal die
Chatkontrolle wieder ausgepackt. Das ist also auch so ein ermüdender Prozess.
Was ist denn jetzt, also was ist denn eure Erfolgsformel, würde man als Boulevardjournalist
fragen, aber vielleicht kann man tatsächlich mal, hast du einen Verdacht,
warum das in Österreich in manchen Sachen eben halt besser klappt?
Jetzt ist so ein totaler banaler Verdacht ist, ihr habt halt einfach sehr viel weniger Einwohner.
Ihr habt sozusagen 10 Millionen Leute, wir haben 80 Millionen Leute.
Es ist vielleicht einfacher.
Eine laute Anzahl Stimmen zusammenbekommen, wenn die Gesamtheit 10 Millionen
ist, als es das bei 80 Millionen ist. Bist du das spielt eine Rolle?
Also wir sind ein Zehntel Deutschlands, so knapp unter 9 Millionen EinwohnerInnen.
Und sicherlich die Größe des Landes macht einen großen Unterschied.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Tanja, bitte widersprich mir, aber hauptsächlich sehe ich,
dass die Qualität unserer Politik noch mal viel schlechter ist als die in Deutschland.
Also wir haben echt Personal, Für das du dich schämst.
Auch in Spitzenpositionen.
Also Dobrindt?
Ja. Also ich glaube, wir würden, wenn ihr mal irgendwie so Interviews mit österreichischen
PolitikerInnen und Deutschen nebeneinander legt,
wo Österreich gut ist und das ist immer noch, glaube ich, so ein Überbleibsel
der K&K-Monarchie, ist halt die Verwaltung.
Die Verwaltung bei uns ist in vielen Dingen gut und da, wo sie auf Autopilot
funktionieren kann, schauen schon manchmal ganz gute Sachen raus.
Also gerade bei E-Government hat das gut funktioniert. Da, wo Institutionen
sich streiten, Stichwort zum Beispiel Gesundheits- oder Bildungspolitik oder
wo Föderalismus dazu kommt,
da ist das Resultat eher schlechter, weil dann die Verwaltung auch Spielräume
wegnimmt und Visionen Gänze zu Gänze fehlen.
Ich glaube schon, dass gewisse Grundprinzipien in Österreich verstanden wurden,
dass wir halt manche Dinge halt auch einfach effizient machen wollen.
Also wie gesagt, E-Government, da sind ein paar Sachen echt gut,
also auch schon in die Jahre gekommen, da müsste man modernisieren,
aber Weichenstellungen wurden getroffen,
schon Anfang der 2000er, noch bevor unser Verein auf die Bühne kam,
die gut sind und auf die man aufbauen kann.
Und ich glaube auch, dass die Innenminister der Bundesländer in Deutschland
vielleicht mit ein Grund sind, wieso die Überwachungsdebatte bei euch halt anders geführt wird.
Wir haben nur einen Innenminister, mit dem wir kämpfen müssen.
Ihr habt irgendwie ganz viele davon.
Verdammter Föderalismus!
Ja, und bei uns gibt es halt niemanden auf Bundesländerebene,
der sich jetzt mit diesen Überwachungsthemen brüsten könnte und damit ständig
neuen Forderungen nach vorne prescht.
Ich glaube, dass das strukturell so ein kleiner Vorteil ist, den wir haben.
Tanja, würdest du noch andere Punkte sehen, wieso es strukturell vielleicht
bei uns manchmal besser läuft?
Mir fällt da jetzt nichts akut Neues ein, als Dinge, die du eh schon gesagt hast.
Ich glaube, der Unterschied ist tatsächlich auch ein großer Teil der Föderalismus,
den wir vielleicht, man könnte jetzt sagen, nicht ganz so ernst nehmen.
Aber nein, die Verfassung gibt es bei uns halt einfach nicht her.
Naja, es gibt vielleicht noch einen Aspekt, den man zumindest,
wenn man auch so ein bisschen an Pannantier denkt, erwähnen muss.
Ich meine, an dem Beispiel von dem US-Konzern sieht man ja, wie der sich so
langsam wieder expandierend in Europa vorgeht, so seine Software-Dienstleistungen
anbietet und da ist natürlich Deutschland sicherlich sexy hier,
einfach weil da mehr zu holen ist.
Die expandieren sehr stark in diesen öffentlichen Bereich, also Polizei und
Geheimdienste, aber auch Verwaltung und Gesundheitswesen Und dann gucken die
natürlich eher nach Deutschland, Frankreich oder Großbritannien,
wo große Märkte gibt, viel zu hohen Millionenverträge, als sie vielleicht zuerst
bei Österreich anfangen.
Dafür habe ich natürlich ein gewisses Verständnis aus Anbietersicht,
aber ich glaube deswegen ist es gerade so dann, wenn große kommerzielle Interessen entstehen.
Da auch noch eine Rolle spielen, dann ist natürlich Deutschland immer prädestiniert als Markt.
Ich finde es total interessant, weil jetzt hier gerade viel erklärt wird,
warum politischer Diskurs in Österreich stellenweise besser funktionieren kann
und auch konsistentere Ergebnisse bringt.
Und trotzdem habt ihr sozusagen, seid ihr, du hast es ja gesagt,
die FPÖ seid ja noch in der Regierung, habt ihr sozusagen so ein Rechts,
also ich weiß nicht, ob größeres Rechtsproblem des richtigen Wortes,
Aber die Frage ist zu sagen, warum klappt es in der Netzpolitik und nicht mit,
keine Ahnung, normaler sozialer Politik.
Das finde ich schon sehr verwunderlich. Aber das ist vielleicht nicht die Podcast-Folge,
in der wir das klären können.
Nee, nicht eine ganz andere Sache. Dazu komme ich gleich. Eine Frage,
die ich noch habe, ist, ich kenne aus Deutschland sozusagen,
haben so netzpolitische Debatten so einen ganz typischen Ablauf.
Nämlich entweder wird ein Gesetz beschlossen
oder irgendjemand veröffentlicht einen Referentenentwurf, wo totaler Quatsch
drin steht und dann gibt es einen riesen Aufschrei
und dann halt wahlweise eine riesige öffentliche Diskussion bis hin zu öffentlichem
Widerstand. Dann wird das Ganze irgendwie wieder einkassiert oder zumindest
sehr stark abgeschwächt.
Oder es interessiert niemanden so richtig und dann passiert es halt doch.
Oder es wird nach zehn Jahren wieder versucht. Wie ist das bei euch? Läuft das da so ähnlich?
Oder gibt es da konstruktivere Formen, der Zusammenarbeit vielleicht sogar
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Also es gibt, jedes Mal, wenn eine Regierung in
Österreich ins Amt kommt, analysieren wir natürlich das Koalitionsabkommen und
geben in Ampelfarben eine Einschätzung zu allem, was netzpolitisch Relevantes ab.
Und das sind klare Themen, wo man sich bekämpfen wird. Und da schenkt man sich natürlich nichts.
Also der Staatstreuer, der Bundestreuer war jetzt ein gutes Beispiel.
Und frage uns nicht, wieso gerade am Anfang dieser neuen Regierung,
die Österreich seit Anfang diesen Jahres hat, eines unserer Kernthemen das große Thema war.
Natürlich, das war ein enormer Infight, der auch viel in den Medien ausgetragen wurde.
Und das ist zuerst aber trotzdem so,
ich glaube, das kann ich sagen, auch wenn es klar ist, dass man sich da auf
der, wie man in Österreich sagen würde, auf der Blutwiese gegenübersteht,
trotzdem gibt es davor die Termine, wo das Ministerium uns einlädt und sagt,
okay gut, wir machen es jetzt.
Gibt es irgendwas, wo man entschärfen kann? Gibt es irgendwelche Dinge,
wo sozusagen es nicht ganz so scheiße sein kann?
Also wie können wir uns so ein paar Kritikpunkte von euch sparen?
Also man versucht da schon auch, obwohl wir der Hauptkritiker sind dieser Maßnahme,
so ein bisschen auf uns zuzugehen.
Und das ist halt auch, weil man weiß, die sachliche Kritik am Ende,
wenn sie da zu viel falsch machen, geben sie uns auch mehr Munition vom Höchstgerecht.
Und man versucht dann schon auch irgendwie so ein bisschen immer,
An Konsens zu finden. Das ist vielleicht auch was zutiefst österreichisches.
Und ja, bei anderen Themen ist es dann total konsoliant.
Also ich weiß nicht, wen jetzt zum Beispiel der Katastrophenschutz vorhat,
eine App zu machen und die dann wirklich schon in der Planungsphase an uns zugehen
und sagen so, hey, wir würden da gerne je nach Demografie des Haushaltes spezifische Warnungen ausgeben,
weil wenn da jemand mit Rollstuhl ist und es kommt dann Hochwasser,
Aber wir wollen die Daten gar nicht haben. Wie ginge das?
Das sind dann auch so Sachen, wo eigentlich auf eine gute Art und Weise Arbeit
passiert, von der im besten Fall niemals jemand mitbekommen wird.
Weil das sind dann halt einfach Projekte, die entstehen auf eine gute Art und
Weise, sodass niemals irgendwer dazu eine Datenschutzfrage haben wird.
Ganz wichtig ist, dass wir für diese Arbeit niemals Geld nehmen,
weil es kann uns immer passieren, dass die Medien dann fragen,
was wir davon halten. und da müssen wir neutral Auskunft geben können.
Genau, über das Geld will ich nachher auch noch reden, aber ich wollte jetzt
noch über etwas ganz anderes reden, weil alles, was ihr jetzt macht,
könnte man fast auch sagen, klingt so ähnlich wie das, was zum Beispiel ein CCC macht,
aber in bezahlt und wie gesagt, über das Geld und was das macht,
wo das herkommt, so will ich gleich noch reden, aber ihr entwickelt auch freie
Software, also unter dem Label Epicenter Works auch. Welche und warum?
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch alles aus der Not heraus entstanden.
Wir machen teilweise Online-Kampagnen.
Safety-Internet.eu, da haben
wir damals auch Faxe ans Europaparlament verschickt für Netzneutralität.
Und wir haben auch bei den Upload-Filtern in der EU-Urheberrechtsrichtlinie
ein Telefon-Tool gebaut, um Europaabgeordnete zu kontaktieren.
Und das ist ganz oft so Right-Once-Software, für die man sich schämt.
Und wir haben aber dann auch hin und wieder so das Bedürfnis,
eigentlich da so ein bisschen die Demokratie als Ganze nach vorne zu bringen.
Und wir glauben, der Weg für Menschen mit ihren gewählten VolksvertreterInnen
in Kontakt zu treten, ist ein essentieller Bestandteil.
Also die Theory of Changes, die Entscheidungen werden besser,
wenn wir die PolitikerInnen nicht mit den Loweisten alleine lassen.
Und dafür haben wir die MEP.eu jetzt gebaut.
Das ist eine Software, die es einfach machen soll, für NGOs zu beliebigen Themen,
Kampagnen, Anrufkampagnen fürs Europaparlament zu machen.
Ist ursprünglich entwickelt worden für die Chatkontrolle.
Und da gab es aber nie eine Plenumsabstimmung, weil man sich ja schon im Ausschuss
einig wurde. Und deswegen haben wir das jetzt veröffentlicht.
Es wird auch später dieses Jahr noch verwendet werden im Klimaschutzbereich.
Da laufen schon die Vorbereitungen.
Das ist eine freie Software, als AGPL lizenziert, also so, dass es auch in allen
seinen Ausprägungen frei bleibt, weil die Hoffnung ist, dass damit halt der
Weg ins Parlament kürzer wird für alle.
Und wir haben uns auch dagegen entschieden, dass wir entscheiden,
wer das verwenden soll, sondern das soll für alle gleich lang oder kurz sein.
Und die Hoffnung ist auch, dass Demokratie gestärkt wird, wenn Menschen erleben,
dass ihre Stimme Gehör hat in diesem Prozess.
Also ich glaube, Demokratie kann nur dann überleben, wenn Menschen mehr tun,
als alle paar Jahre zur Wahl zu gehen. Ich glaube, das ist zu wenig.
Ich finde es ganz anders, aber frage mich gleichzeitig auch,
es gibt ja die, also es gibt so Meme oder Klischee-Geschichten aus Deutschland,
wo dann gesagt wird, naja, irgendwie ist es ja schön, wenn ihr an PolitikerInnen
tausend E-Mails schreibt, aber der einzelne handgeschriebene Brief hat dann trotzdem mehr Gewicht.
So eine Tools, wenn sie digital sind, könnt ihr ja immer auch sozusagen zu so
einer Vermassung und Gamifizierung führen.
Habt ihr da schon irgendwie mal Feedback erhalten, wie viel das dann wirklich
bringt, wenn man das Also es klingt ja also schön, man macht es möglichst einfach
mit der Politik in Kontakt zu bekommen,
aber das kann natürlich auch zu einer Lawine führen, die man dann einfach ignoriert,
weil sie so groß ist, weil es so viel ist.
Absolut, also ja, wie gesagt, wir haben dieses Tool oder dieses Prinzip ja 2019
bei den Upload-Filtern schon zum Einsatz gebracht.
Und es ist bewusst hier ein Telefontool, weil alle anderen Wege sind schon verbrannt.
Faxe kommen im Outlook an, das ist auch ein bisschen unsere Schuld.
Social Media, E-Mail, das ist alles in Zeiten von LLMs, also von Chat-GPT und
derartigen Modellen, nichts, was noch eine Authentizität hat.
Das kann von einer Maschine auch sein. Und da gibt es ja auch Kampagnen,
die dann einfach einzigartige E-Mails einfach on the fly erstellen lassen Und
man muss als User nur noch klicken, klicken, klicken.
Die eine Sache, wo wir glauben, dass
wir aktuell noch, und das ändert sich vielleicht in zwei, drei Jahren,
so ein bisschen ein Fenster haben, ist, wenn Menschen wirklich in Echtzeit in
ihrer eigenen Mundart, im Dialekt mit Abgeordneten aus ihrer Region sprechen.
Ich glaube, dass wir da wirklich noch direkt Menschen miteinander verbinden
können und das eben nicht automatisiert so leicht werden kann.
Und genau da will die MEP halt eben jetzt gerade diese Lücke noch nutzen und
eben wirklich Menschen mit ihren Abgeordneten verbinden oder zumindest mit deren Büros.
Und weil es ein riesiger Ask ist, den Hörer in die Hand zu nehmen,
haben wir halt Call-Abonnements, dass man sagen kann, du kannst jeden Mittwoch
um 9 Uhr oder um 14 Uhr, wirst du angerufen von unserem Tool.
Und das verbindet dich mit jenen Abgeordneten, die jetzt gerade am ehesten zu überzeugen sind.
Und das Tool lernt auch mit, sodass es immer nur die noch Unentschiedenen,
den Movable Middle in diesem Thema kontaktiert.
Und jene, die eh schon unserer Meinung sind, oder die Axel Vosses dieser Welt,
die eh immer gegen uns sind, die müssen wir gar nicht kontaktieren,
sondern es geht um jene, die noch zu erreichen sind.
Und wenn zehn Leute sagen, ich habe die Person überzeugt, dann lernt das,
tut das und nimmt sich die nächsten Abgeordneten vor.
Es ist schon wirklich der Versuch, Mehrheiten zu gewinnen bei diesen komplexen Themen.
Es gibt so der alte Spruch, ja, Lobbyisten haben Kunden, wir haben Überzeugungen,
wir haben auch keine Geldkoffer und keine Arbeitsplätze als Argument,
aber wir haben halt die Menschen auf unserer Seite.
Und das wollen wir hier mit so einer Software halt nutzen, dass NGOs die Unterstützung
in der Bevölkerung für diese Themen halt auch in die Waagschale werfen bei diesen
politischen Abstimmungen.
Glaubt ihr sozusagen, weil du von einem Fenster gesprochen hast,
dass dann irgendwann in den PolitikerInnenbüros so Voice-Chat-Bots ans Gerät gehen?
Also eine Anrufzentrale kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen nach der Europawahl.
Also jetzt diesen Term für die nächsten vier Jahre, glaube ich,
dass das noch ein sinnvolles Tool ist, das einen Impact haben kann,
aber das ist immer ein Kratz-und-Maus-Spiel.
Und es war bisher immer so, dass jede erfolgreiche Strategie,
die wir eingesetzt haben, mit der Zeit sich abnützt und verbrennt.
Aber das ist die Natur der Sache leider.
Immer wenn man rausgefunden hat, wie man mit Politiker reden kann,
entziehen sie sich. Da ist doch irgendwo ein Fehler im System. Anyways.
Aber apropos Leute erreichen, macht ihr auch Social Media?
Ja, wir sind auf fast allen Kanälen unterwegs, auf Mastodon, auf Blue Sky,
immer noch auf X, auf Insta, auf YouTube relativ stark mit den ganzen Archiven
von allen möglichen Videocontent, den wir produzieren.
Das wichtigste aber eigentlich ist für uns der Newsletter, den wir haben und
der Blog, der auch über RSS abonnierbar ist,
also das sind die zwei wichtigsten Kanäle, um uns zu folgen es gibt auch monatliche
Treffen, die wir haben einmal im Quartal Stopp.
Stopp, stopp, stopp Werbeblog nachher ich will erst mal über die Arbeit wissen
und entschuldige jetzt auch rumhacke, aber einen X-Account, really man unterstützt
ja damit eine Fascho-Plattform
Das stimmt. Aber wenn du mit PolitikerInnen auf diesen Plattformen kämpfen willst,
die sind leider dort alle immer noch.
Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Fakt in Deutschland. Das ist nicht nur in Österreich so.
Ich bin auch erstaunt, wie die Spitzenpolitik in Deutschland immer noch da ist.
Das ist echt erstaunlich.
Also wir waren von Anfang an auf Mastodon. Das wäre auch jene Plattform,
die wir am meisten uns wünschen würden, dass die Debatte sich dorthin verlagert.
Blue Sky ist in Österreich sehr groß geworden mit der Übernahme von Musk von
Twitter und der Umbenennung zu X.
Es ist fast der komplette journalistische Betrieb in Österreich von Twitter
weg, nach Blue Sky hin abgewandert.
Aber die PolitikerInnen, die Ministerien und auch viele andere öffentliche Einrichtungen
sind immer noch dort. Und das ist halt leider auch so ein bisschen die Zielgruppe,
mit der wir uns streiten müssen.
Und deswegen sind wir auch immer noch dort. Aber wir bespielen alle drei Medien
so, dass es keinen Unterschied macht, wo die Leute sind.
Europa ist es leider auch so. Ich stelle fest, also gerade so,
wenn man jetzt Themen hat, die auch in Brüssel lernen, gerade so wieder bei
der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, erstaunlich, wie viel sich da immer noch bei Twitter abspielt.
Auch so ein bisschen, wenn die Informationen raustun, zum Beispiel aus den europäischen
Ausschüssen, kannst du in der Regel immer noch zuerst auf Twitter,
also X lesen, bin ich auch erstaunt drüber.
Ekelhaft. Aber gut. Dann kommen wir jetzt zum lieben Geld.
Anni, kann ich noch eine Frage zu den Sprachen stellen, was mir aufgefallen ist? Geht das noch?
Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade die akustisch nicht verstanden. Was geht noch?
Ich würde gerne noch eine Frage zu den Sprachen stellen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, gerade auch als ich mit Tanja zusammengearbeitet habe für
die UN-Cybercrank-Convention,
dass ihr manchmal English First macht quasi, dass ihr euch eher an das internationale
Publikum richtet und englische Pressemitteilungen macht, die ihr auch manchmal gar nicht übersetzt,
obwohl ihr ja sozusagen in Österreich ansässig seid.
Wie ist denn da so eure Kommunikationsstrategie, gerade bei internationalen Themen?
Das ist wirklich getrieben davon, also wenn wir auf EU- oder UN-Ebene arbeiten,
dann ist das English first.
Und da geht es ja dann auch eher darum, EntscheiderInnen zu erreichen,
die gar kein Deutsch sprechen und auch über Medien das Ganze zu spielen,
die nichts mit dem Dachraum zu tun haben.
Und das ist einfach getrieben davon, was das Thema braucht. Und ein Vorteil
ist, in so einem kleinen Land zu sein, ist, dass man sich selber nicht sehr wichtig nimmt.
Und deswegen verbringen wir die Hälfte unserer Energie halt auch auf EU- und UN-Themen.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, nur österreichische Politik zu machen, da würden wir alle verrückt werden.
Aber ihr habt dann gar nicht den Bedarf, das überhaupt zu übersetzen.
Also ihr bleibt dann einfach bei nur Englisch, habe ich festgestellt,
bei manchen Themen, gerade so bei der Cybercrack Convention.
Bei der Cybercrime Convention war es tatsächlich so, dass wir sehr viele Stellungnahmen
hatten und eben auch Briefe, die wir gemeinsam mit Organisationen dann auch verfasst haben.
Die waren auf Englisch von Haus aus alleine, weil die Personen,
die daran geschrieben haben, Englisch als gemeinsame Sprache hatten.
Wir haben auch eine Pressekonferenz in Wien gemacht, Thomas,
die du damals moderiert hast mit mir und ein paar anderen KollegInnen von anderen
Organisationen, eben auch von Article 19 und IFF, unter anderem am Panel.
Die war auf Englisch, war auch tatsächlich vor allem an internationale,
nicht ausschließlich, wir haben den großen österreichischen Presseverteiler damals auch bedient,
aber auch an internationale Medien und das hatte gerade bei der UN folgenden
Grund, es geht da sehr stark,
um die Meinung von Staaten insofern zu beeinflussen, als dass sie sich dann
der einen oder anderen Seite, wie es eben bei der Cybercrime Convention war, anschließen.
Und da ging es zunächst einmal wirklich um größere Staaten.
Und Englisch war tatsächlich dann die Sprache, die wir als gemeinsame Sprache hatten.
Wir hatten auch, sollte ich vielleicht dazusagen, weil zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
in den Verhandlungen in Lateinamerika so wichtig war, haben wir eine Pressekonferenz
bei uns im Büro gemacht, die war virtuell, die war auf Spanisch.
Es war tatsächlich in der Zeit den Umständen geschuldet, aber prinzipiell haben
wir da keine English-First-Strategie, im Gegenteil.
Also wir haben sowohl unsere Blogposts, unsere Einträge, unsere Website gibt
es auf Deutsch sowie auf Englisch und da ist mal Deutsch zumeist die erste Sprache.
Ja, und wenn wir zum Beispiel dann, wir haben schon gemeinsame Briefe mit lateinamerikanischen
NGOs gemacht, auch rund um dieses kolumbianische Gerichtsverfahren,
das war eigentlich Spanish First.
Wir haben relativ viel zu diesem Digital Identity Thema gemacht,
das dann taiwanesische Schwesterorganisationen auf Mandarinkinesisch übersetzt haben.
Also wir versuchen da auch möglichst international zu arbeiten,
weil das ist sowohl Qualitätssicherung wie auch einfach, um sich gegenseitig zu unterstützen.
Aber ich erinnere mich, Constanze, als wir das Gespräch damals hatten zu dem
Podcast, den ich mit dir und deiner Kollegin damals machen durfte,
war es für mich gar nicht so einfach, das Thema auf Deutsch zu präsentieren.
Einfach, weil ich nie darüber auf Deutsch gesprochen habe,
Weil ich nie auf Deutsch geschrieben habe. Man muss ja auch die Begriffe kennen, die Fachbegriffe.
Die Fachbegriffe, die juristischen Spezifikationen, all das,
das war damals wirklich schwierig und ich erinnere mich noch genau daran.
So, dann kommen wir jetzt zum lieben Geld. Das klang ja schon mal an und ihr
seid ja zwei von acht oder neun, glaube ich, festangestellten Leuten,
die Epicenter Work sozusagen im Kern sind, zusätzlich zu den Vereinsmitgliedern, nehme ich an.
So und das heißt da müssen halt irgendwie so eine Handvoll Leute oder zwei Handvoll
Leute fast bezahlt werden und so internationale Sachen kosten ja auch irgendwie
Geld wenn man da, da entstehen ja auch sozusagen einfach Kosten gerade wenn man mal wohin will
wo kommt denn das Geld her ich würde jetzt sagen irgendwie der Verein hat vielleicht
eine Vereinsmitgliedschaft dann gibt es wahrscheinlich Spenden,
du hast schon Stiftungen erwähnt, wie vielleicht kannst du ein bisschen mehr
darüber erzählen oder könnt ihr ein bisschen mehr darüber erzählen,
wo kommt das her, wie setzt das zusammen und welche Konditionen sind damit verbunden?
Ja, also uns gibt es nur, weil es genügend Menschen gibt, die uns Geld in den
Hut werfen und uns das Ganze ermöglichen.
Also ohne Spenden, ohne regelmäßige Fördermitglieder wäre diese Arbeit überhaupt nicht zu leisten.
Das sind zum Glück einige tausend Menschen,
die wir uns da aufgebaut haben über die Jahre und wir können ungefähr die Hälfte
von unserem Budget eben mit Spenden und Fördermitgliedern decken und den anderen
Rest stopseln wir uns zusammen, wo es irgendwie geht.
Das sind Stiftungen, ganz viel zum Beispiel Open Society Foundation, als es die noch gab.
Die sind ja inzwischen implodiert und weggefallen.
Aber es ist eben auch zum Beispiel die Stadt Wien ist Fördermitglied bei uns
mit 25.000 Euro. Die Arbeiterkammer unterstützt uns immer wieder.
Andere Stiftungen, da suchen wir, soweit es geht, irgendwie über Wasser zu bleiben,
um den Betrieb zu erhalten.
Unsere Hoffnung wäre, dass wir es irgendwann nur mit Fördermitgliedern und Spenden
schaffen und komplett auf die Stiftungen verzichten können.
Aber das sind wir halt leider noch nicht.
Es gibt, wer sich dafür interessiert, auf epicenter.org slash Transparenz,
die jährlichen Berichte, wo das
alles genau aufgelistet ist und dann auch monatliche Cashflow-Berichte,
wo man genau zuschauen kann, wie die Kohle rein und raus geht und woher sie
kommt und wohin sie geht.
Der allergrößte Teil geht auf die Personalkosten drauf. Wie gesagt,
wir haben neun MitarbeiterInnen.
Wir sind mit mir drei Leute in der Policy, zwei Leute in der Kommunikation und
dann halt Technik und Admin.
Und wir haben separat auch noch eine Epicenter Academy.
Das ist eine GmbH, die dem Verein gehört, die aber nur Bildung macht.
Die geht an Schulen, weil inzwischen schon an über 500 Schulklassen in den letzten
zweieinhalb Jahren, seit es die gibt und unterrichtet dort digitale Grundbildung.
Nicht unähnlich dem, was Chaos macht, Schule tut, mit auch einem freien E-Learning,
das man sich anschauen kann und auch in jedes Moodle und sonstige E-Learning
integrieren kann. Alles frei lizenziert.
Und du hast vorher auch die Mitglieder erwähnt, also wir haben eine Governance.
Dadurch, dass wir früher ja nur Ehrenamtliche waren, ist es noch heute ehrenamtliche
Arbeit noch immer ganz wichtig.
Über diese monatlichen Treffen versuchen wir auch immer wieder neue Leute dazu
zu gewinnen, die in irgendeiner Form mitarbeiten bei dem Verein.
Und wer das ein bisschen kontinuierlicher tut, kriegt auch die Vollmitgliedschaft
angeboten, über die man dann eben auch den Vorstand wählt und den ganzen Betrieb
und auch die inhaltliche Ausrichtung kontrollieren kann.
Also unser Konzept ist, dass wir kontinuierlich aus der Community Menschen rekrutieren,
um auch eine demokratische Verankerung des Vereins zu haben,
sodass wir da einfach immer ein Korrektiv haben mit Menschen,
die dann netzpolitische Themen wichtig sind, die dann halt einfach auch die
großen Weichenstellungen mit beeinflussen können.
Wie ist das bei den Stiftungen? Geben die euch einfach Geld,
weil sie sagen, jetzt banal, wir finden euch toll oder läuft das eher über so
Projektanträge, dass sie sagt, wir wollen dieses Jahr dies und das machen, gebt uns dafür Geld?
Beides. Also wir haben teilweise Core-Grants bekommen, die einfach wirklich
nur für das, was wir tun, teilweise eben auch für die Arbeit an Netzneutralität oder Digital Identity,
die wir ja schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren machen und das wird gesehen und
dann sagt man halt, okay, macht mehr davon, macht das weiter.
Es waren aber auch Projektgelder, zum Beispiel damals, als wir im Urheberrecht
aktiv waren, das waren alles eher so Projektfinanzierungen.
Es gibt schon eine Tendenz, eher in Richtung Core Grants zu gehen,
weil bei uns sind Projekte oft etwas, dass wir am Sonntag kommt die Idee und
am Dienstag fangen wir an damit.
Da ist nicht die Zeit, irgendwie einen Projektantrag zu schreiben.
Wir haben jetzt eine Sache, wo wir Projektgelder eingeworben haben.
Und das ist eine freie Software, die wir bauen für EIDAS Oversight,
um da Accountability zu schaffen mit einer Open Data Plattform.
Und das ist ein zweijähriges Projekt, das wir gerade gestartet haben.
Und da sind wir mit dem Klingelbeuten rumgegangen und haben uns Geld eingesammelt.
Also EIDAS ist der europäische Versuch sozusagen so eine Art elektronische Identität zu schaffen?
Ganz genau. Ja, an dem Gesetz haben wir ganz lange mitgearbeitet.
Die Policyarbeit hat keinen interessiert, hat keiner finanziert.
Aber jetzt, wo das Gesetz fertig ist und sozusagen die freie Software,
die es dann ermöglicht, in Echtzeit nachzuverfolgen, welche Firma oder staatliche
Stelle fragt, was von den Menschen an, zu welchem Zweck,
sodass man sich auch in Echtzeit alert setzen kann, wenn irgendwas in eine falsche
Richtung geht, das bauen wir gerade und das wird Ende 26 fertig.
Bringt euch das sozusagen in eine Zwickmühle in der Hinsicht sozusagen,
dann müsste ja pro IIDAS sein, weil wenn es IIDAS nicht mehr gibt,
dann habt ihr kein Projekt mehr.
Naja, das ist ein EU-Gesetz, das beschlossen wurde. Insofern,
der Gesetzgeber hat sich entschieden, dass es das geben soll.
Wir waren von Anfang an sehr kritisch bei diesem Vorhaben. Wir haben aber auch
gesehen, das komplett abzuschaffen, wäre weder sinnvoll noch politisch möglich gewesen.
Sondern unsere Einstellung war immer, dieses System wird so viel Impact haben
auf die Art, wie wir digital mit dem Staat, aber auch mit der Privatwirtschaft interagieren,
dass man einfach schauen muss, dass das Ganze grundrechtskonformer,
datenschutztauglich umgesetzt wird.
Und da haben wir sozusagen jetzt auch mit dem Softwareprojekt ja nur vor,
dass wir Transparenz darüber schaffen, wie wird es jetzt wirklich verwendet,
Um auch so ein Frühwarnsystem zu haben, wenn etwas in eine falsche Richtung geht.
Und der digitale Euro ist ein weiteres Beispiel, wo wir dieselbe Einstellung haben.
Wir haben da auch massive Bauchschmerzen, was den Datenschutz und die IT-Sicherheit betrifft.
Aber wir waren jetzt nicht komplett dagegen, weil es macht schon Sinn,
dass wir digitale Bezahlsysteme in Europa haben, die nicht aus den USA kommen.
Im Moment sind alle, die wir verwenden, aus den USA.
Ich stelle fest, ihr seid sehr viel realpolitischer als zum Beispiel ein CCC.
Wir müssen uns als CCC ja auch um Finanzen keine Sorgen machen und ich habe
fast den Eindruck, ich werde es vielleicht mal deutlich machen,
weil es jetzt so klang, als seid ihr schon alles prima.
Mein Eindruck in den letzten Jahren, auch gerade so über diese Pandemiezeit
ist, dass viele netzpolitische Vereine am Existenzabgrund krebeln und dass da
auch Epizenter drunter ist.
Ich finde diese Selbstverständlichkeit, mit der viele Leute glauben,
dass Aktivismus gemacht wird,
dass Leute sich inhaltlich mit Sachen beschäftigen und dazu eine kompetente
Meinung abgeben, es nervt mich tierisch, wie Leute glauben, das ist selbstverständlich
und niemand muss sich dafür engagieren.
Mich stört es sehr, dass nicht genug Leute zusammenkommen, um so etwas zu bezahlen.
Ich finde, es klang jetzt sehr, weil Thomas auch so ein bisschen diese Art hat,
sehr rosig. Wir haben hier verschiedene Finanzquellen.
Die Wahrheit ist, dass es viel zu wenig Leute gibt, die dafür spenden und sich
für auch gerade so eine langfristige Arbeit einsetzen und sagen,
hey, das ist mir irgendeine Summe wert, ja.
Also das klingt jetzt alles so, ja, wir machen das, wir sind an den Themen dran,
aber die Wahrheit ist, dass es nicht nur in Österreich und Deutschland,
sondern in anderen europäischen Ländern kenne ich ähnliche Beispiele,
dass es schlimm ist, die Finanzierung dafür zu kriegen.
Und ich will noch mal was drittes erwähnen.
Wir haben eine krasse Veränderung in der Art, wie technologische Überwachung
und auch noch ein paar andere netzpolitische Themen gesehen werden in Europa.
Das ist ein richtiger Schiff.
Also eine ganz deutliche Verschiebung. Und sich dagegen zu wehren,
auch so mit Argumenten, wird immer schwieriger. Also ich glaube, dass die
Leute, die die Arbeit gut finden, müssen sich für die Finanzierung einsetzen.
Das ist ein wichtiger Anliegen. Aber einerseits total verständlich und ja,
aber andererseits ist ja der CCC, also alles was im CCC passiert,
passiert tatsächlich ehrenamtlich.
Und das ist ja auch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, eine bewusste Entscheidung,
das nicht nur so gemacht zu haben, sondern das auch so zu halten.
Weil der Vorteil sozusagen eines bezahlten Aktivismus ist, man hat mehr Zeit, sich dem zu widmen.
Aber der Nachteil oder die Kehrseite der Medaille, könnte man sagen,
ist, man ist halt eher in der Realpolitik drin und man muss sich halt auf einmal um Geld kümmern.
Ja, ganz genau. Und vor allen Dingen hat man überhaupt diese Probleme, natürlich.
Aber Markus, da würde ich dir widersprechen. Also wenn ich jetzt als NGO einfach
nur auf meine Finanzen schaue, dann würde ich überhaupt keine Realpolitik machen.
Dann wäre es auch am zielführendsten, einfach immer dagegen zu sein und immer
nur aufzuschreien und auch gar nicht irgendwie versuchen, eine Mehrheit irgendwie anzusprechen,
sondern eher nur mit meiner Bubble, mit meiner Nische zu kommunizieren.
Weil es wird immer eine Minderheit sein, die sich an dem Thema so nahe fühlt,
dass sie dafür auch bereit ist zu spenden.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist da auch nur ein Gespräch mit...
Einer Institution, einem Ministerium, die nicht deiner Meinung ist,
eine Gefahr unter Anführungszeichen.
Also da ist die Balance, die wir wahren müssen, indem wir einerseits klar dagegen
sind und so laut auch beißen, dass wir zum Beispiel niemals eine staatliche
Förderung bekommen würden von diesen Einrichtungen.
Ja ökonomisch eigentlich ein Schuss ins Knie, vor allem wenn du dann auf der
anderen Seite dem Innenministerium auch sagst, Tietos mit dem Zensus habt ihr aber gut gemacht.
Also ich glaube, das ist schon eine schwierige Haltung.
Und um an das anzuschließen, was Konstanze gesagt hat, also wir hatten zweimal
in unserer Geschichte schon die Situation, dass wir fast zahlungsunfähig gewesen wären.
Einmal 2020 mitten in der Pandemiehochphase und einmal im Oktober letzten Jahres
mussten wir mit einem großen Hilferuf an die Öffentlichkeit.
Und zum Glück kamen dann genügend Menschen zu unserer Rettung.
Aber wir hätten auch 2024 nicht überlebt, wenn da nicht genügend Menschen eine
Fördermitgliedschaft abgeschlossen hätten, damit es uns weiterhin gibt.
Also das ist schon immer noch eine Sache, die von ganz vielen Einzelpersonen
getragen wird oder eben nicht.
Das andere Gegenargument gegen finanzierten Aktivismus ist ja die,
wenn der eigene Lebensunterhalt davon abhängt, dann kann ich das Problem nie überflüssig machen.
Also ich bin darauf angewiesen, dass es ein Problem gibt, gegen das ich kämpfe,
weil sonst ist meine Lebensgrundlage weg.
Und die Frage ist natürlich zu sagen, wie seht ihr das? Jetzt kann man natürlich
sozusagen sagen, ja gut, es gibt genug Probleme auf der Welt,
wird sich schon immer was finden.
Aber seht ihr diese Gefahr auch? Oder merkt ihr die manchmal?
So, jetzt ist es gerade ruhig, jetzt ist gerade kein Skandal.
Oh Gott, die Mitglieder brichen weg.
Also wir hatten dieses Problem noch nie, insofern ist es theoretisch.
Bei Netzneutralität kann ich nur sagen, ich habe mir das Thema damals ausgesucht,
am Anfang, als es noch mein Hobby war, dieser Aktivismus, weil ich dachte,
das ist lösbar. In so fünf, sechs Jahren haben wir das abgehakt.
Wir könnten uns wichtigeren Dingen widmen.
Es ist nur leider immer wieder auf die Agenda gehoben worden von mächtigen Industrieinteressen,
hier vor allem der Telekom-Industrie.
Und deswegen haben wir es immer wieder verhandeln müssen. Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass wir gewisse Themen auch abhaken können.
Vorrat-Zeitenspeichung, bitte abhaken.
Ja, und es gibt wirklich in der Netzpolitik so viel zu tun, gerade weil Digitalisierung
die Gesellschaft durchdringt.
Da gibt es noch so viele Themen, die auch in unserer Community unterbelichtet sind.
Leider ist da aber immer wieder eher so ein Zurück zum Staat als ein Können wir es bitte abhaken.
Also du hast schon recht, es gibt NGOs, die das Schlimmste, was ihnen passieren
könnte, ist, dass ihr Ziel erreicht wird.
Ich würde es mir für uns wünschen. Und wenn der Sachverstand auch in allen Parteien
so vorhanden wäre, dann bräuchte es uns auch nicht mehr.
Gibt es einen Plan B.
Aber Thomas, dann kommt die UN-Ebene noch dazu, weil da haben sie gerade erst
das Thema Cyber unter Anführungszeichen für sich entdeckt in den vergangenen zwei, drei Jahren.
Ich glaube, da kommt noch einiges und da ist noch einiges, was uns wirklich beschäftigen wird.
Aber jetzt die positive Seite davon könnte man sagen, man hat als Aktivist eben,
man muss sich nicht, also man kann
Vollzeitaktivismus machen und muss halt nicht sich sozusagen das unterteilen
zwischen Erwerbsarbeit und Aktivismus Ist das, also ich meine ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass ihr sozusagen Hochphasen habt und Phasen, wo es ruhiger läuft Ich rede
jetzt nicht von stundenweise Arbeitsbelastung aber bringt das so eine gewisse
Entspannung in der aktivistischen Arbeit, dass man weiß, das ist auch mein Job?
Also macht es die Sache auch einfacher?
Also ich erinnere mich da zurück, mein allererster Job als Zivilliener war bei
ZARA, das ist die Antirassismus-NGO in Österreich, das ist so eine Beratungsstelle
für Opfer und Zeugen von Rassismus.
Und der damalige Chef hat gesagt, wenn man Antirassismus ernst meint,
dann müssen jene, die es sich zum Lebensinhalt machen, auch davon leben können
und das Thema ist so wichtig, um als Hobby abgetan zu werden.
Das ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, der Zugang. Und aus dem erwächst aber auch
eine enorme Verantwortung.
Das ist eine Arbeitsweise, die sehr sorgsam sein muss und auch dem Thema und
sonst nichts verpflichtet.
Ich glaube, sonst kannst du das auch nicht rechtfertigen. Und ja,
man hat, wenn man Aktivismus zu seinem Job oder eher zu seiner Berufung macht,
weniger Bedarf nach Hobbys. Das stimmt schon.
Aber die Argumente würdest du für alle Ehrenamtlichen auch, also ich meine,
jedenfalls solche, die sich fachlich kompetent verstehen.
Ich habe ja gerade so, im Prinzip habe ich ja gefragt, mach das ein bisschen
einfacher. Was ich gerade höre vom Vibe her ist eigentlich nicht.
Es ist trotzdem mega anstrengend, es ist halt so eine Berufung und so weiter und so fort.
Also du hast eher noch viel mehr, dass diese Themen dich dann in deiner Freizeit,
wenn es sowas überhaupt gibt, weiter verfolgen und dass du halt immer auch aktiv bist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man da auch eine Form von Selbstwirksamkeit mal erlebt
hat, dann ist das auch etwas, wo du immer mehr machen willst,
weil es ja unheimlich toll ist, an den Zuständen was zu verändern.
Und ich würde das nie vergessen, irgendwie, wenn du dann halt wirklich mal Gesetze
so ändern kannst, wie du dir das vorstellst, dass ein Text, der Netzseutralität regelt in der EU,
aus den eigenen Händen dann angenommen wird, dann ist das ein unheimlicher Kick.
Ja, oder bei Gerichtsverfahren auch, wenn man was schafft oder wenn dann Aspekte
drin sind, die man wirklich als Sieg, ja, aber das ist ja für Ehrenamtliche genauso.
Würdest du lieber bezahlt Aktivismus machen, Konz? Vielen Dank.
Ach, das ist eine komplexe Frage. Deutschland funktioniert anders.
Also ich stehe hinter der Entscheidung, dass der CCC sich vor vielen Jahren
entschieden hat, so etwas nicht zu machen und komplett ehrenamtlich.
Da stehe ich total dahinter.
Ich arbeite aber mit sehr vielen bezahlten Aktivisten und ich kann verstehen,
dass auch in Deutschland Netzpolitische Vereine einen anderen Weg gehen.
Ich sehe die Vor- und Nachteile.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen für Österreich war es fast ein bisschen alternativlos,
um die Wirksamkeit zu bekommen.
Also das ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck. Aber ich habe auch nicht so viele
Einblicke in die österreichische Szene.
Okay, dann sind wir jetzt für mich zumindest dann ist er beinahe schon am Ende
angekommen und es wurde ja gerade gesagt, es gibt immer Probleme,
es wird weiterhin welche geben, es gibt viel zu tun.
Was wünscht ihr euch denn an netzpolitischer Debatte?
Vielleicht können wir zwei Sachen machen, aber mit der Bitte um kurze Antwort.
Was wünscht ihr euch sozusagen als Ergebnis netzpolitischer Debatten und woran
würdet ihr gerne in der nächsten Zukunft arbeiten?
Was ich mir ganz dringend wünschen würde, ist, dass Gesetze,
das ist ja vor allem die Thematik, mit der ich mich am meisten befasse,
grundrechtskonform angegangen werden.
Und zwar, dass es im Vorfeld, bevor die überhaupt in Begutachtung kommen,
dass es da schon mal eine grundrechtliche, menschenrechtliche Abwägung gibt,
so ähnlich wie eine Datenschutzfolgenabschätzung, aber so richtig gut durchleuchtet
in sämtlichen Bereichen.
Ich glaube, das würde uns alle ein gutes Stück weiterbringen.
Und woran möchtest du als Nächstes am liebsten arbeiten?
Ich bin da ehrlich gesagt ziemlich offen. Ich mache jetzt kein Geheimnis daraus,
dass ich die internationalen Themen der österreichischen Innenpolitik vorziehe.
Aber ich bin da inhaltlich wirklich offen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Alles klar. Und Thomas, wie ist es bei dir?
Was wünschst du dir als Ergebnis?
Naja, also ich glaube,
Mein ehemaliger Chef in Brüssel hat mal diesen schönen Satz gesagt,
es ist dumm, nicht aus den eigenen Fehlern zu lernen, aber es ist noch viel
dümmer, nicht aus den eigenen Erfolgen zu lernen.
Und ich glaube, es ist nicht so lange her, dass in vielen Ländern dieser Welt
Regierungen verstanden haben, nämlich in der Pandemie, dass man eigentlich das
Vertrauen der Bevölkerung braucht, damit gewisse Systeme funktionieren.
Und damit man dieses Vertrauen bekommt, braucht es ein Maximum an Datenschutz
und auch ein Maximum an Transparenz und Inklusion.
Und wenn das nicht vorhanden ist, dann ist es wurscht, was das System tut. Es wird scheitern.
Es wird nicht in der Breite einen positiven Effekt erzielen.
Und ich glaube, diese Erkenntnis müsste man wieder mehr ins Gedächtnis rufen,
wenn wir uns diese großen IT-Projekte anschauen, weil ja unheimlich viel Geld ausgegeben wird.
Dass man da einfach so ein bisschen mehr den Sachverstand, der schon vorhanden
ist in der Gesellschaft, zusammenzieht und kollaborativ solche Dinge als freie Software,
datenschutzkonform und auch ohne amerikanische oder chinesische Konzerne entwickeln könnte,
vielleicht auch eben dann anhand von konkreten gesellschaftlichen Zielvorstellungen.
Das wäre sowas, das ist eigentlich ein No-Brainer.
Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht too much to ask von unserer Politik.
Das wäre so das eine und woran ich gerne arbeiten würde, das ist so ein Hassbegriff.
Nennt sich Digital Public Infrastructures.
Das ist, wie die UN über diese ganzen digitalen Identitätssysteme spricht und
blickt und da gibt es auch sehr viel Entwicklung in diesem Themenfeld.
Ich habe diesen Begriff zuerst gehasst, als ich mit ihm in Kontakt kam und jetzt
langsam versuche ich da immer mehr reinzukommen und das auch mit konkreten,
positiven Visionen aufzuladen, was das heißen kann.
Das ist auch so ein Feld, wo sich gerade sehr viel Zivilgesellschaft abseits
von Europa organisiert, wie man mit solchen Systemen besser umgehen kann.
Manchmal auch, wie man sie vor Gericht wegklagt.
Also an dem würde ich gerne noch viel mehr arbeiten. Also auch so ein bisschen
schon über Europa hinaus, weil man lernt auch so unheimlich viel.
Das übersieht man auch immer, wenn man mal so mit NGOs von ganz anderen Ländern
zu tun hat. Und das ist für beide Seiten unheimlich bereichernd.
Davon hätte ich gerne noch mehr.
Okay, dann noch zwei letzte Fragen noch an euch. Die eine ist,
du hattest vorhin schon mal angefangen.
Niederfick mir was wünschen.
Darf ich vorstellen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, Dr. Konstanze Kurz,
hervorragend eine geplante Dramaturgie zu unterbrechen, um sich selbst um den
goldenen Teppich zu bringen, den ich gerade am Ende noch ausbreiten wollte.
Aber wir kommen noch dazu.
Nein, ich will mir nichts mehr wünschen.
Doch, musst du aber gleich. Aber gleich, Thomas und Tanja, Thomas,
du hast es vorhin schon angefangen zu sagen, bevor ich dich unterbrochen habe,
weil der Werbeblog kommt jetzt, dass es zwei Kanäle gibt, wo man euch besonders
gut folgen kann, nämlich welche?
Ja, das Wichtigste ist einfach der Newsletter.
Der Deutschsprachige kommt so grob alle zwei Wochen, der Englischsprachige jedes Monat.
Das ist, glaube ich, der beste Weg auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben,
was wir so tun, vielleicht auch was in Österreich passiert.
Und wir haben natürlich eben, wie
vorher genannt, alle möglichen sozialen Netzwerke, wo man uns folgen kann.
Aber es gibt auch diese monatlichen Treffen, wo wir uns immer über neue Gesichter
und Menschen, die mitmachen wollen, freuen. Virtuell?
Die sind einmal im Quartal in Wien physisch und ansonsten immer virtuell.
Und ja, wenn das, was wir hier fabrizieren und worüber wir geredet haben,
ein Anliegen ist, Fördermitgliedschaften gibt es ab zwei Euro im Monat und wer
ein bisschen mehr zahlt, kriegt auch ein T-Shirt oder andere Goodies.
Diese Fördermitgliedschaften sind die Basis von allem was wir machen.
Also das wäre die große Bitte, wer uns unterstützen will, bitte überlegt euch
doch eine Fördermitgliedschaft abzuschließen und man kann uns auch spenden auf
allen möglichen Einzelkanälen.
All das findet sich auf der Website und ist auch in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Und weil ich den Kommentar schon vor mir gesehen habe, wieso hast du das nicht
gefragt, warum eigentlich Epicenterworks? Also wofür steht der Name?
Aber eine oft gestellte Frage kommt eigentlich so ein bisschen aus der Geschichte
des Schockwellenreiters und der Idee,
dass Digitalisierung Gesellschaft neu sortiert und dass wir uns im Zentrum dieser
Veränderung sehen, an der Veränderung auch arbeiten.
Oft können wir die nicht steuern, aber wir können ein bisschen helfen,
dass dann vielleicht doch eher menschen- und grundrechtskonform und ein bisschen
mehr auf die Gesellschaft gerichtet diese technische Veränderung passiert.
Und wir arbeiten viel und vieles von dem, was wir machen, zeigt auch Konsequenzen.
Deswegen das Works im Namen.
Sehr gut. Na dann, viel Glück und viel Spaß. Konz.
Ja?
Was wünschst du denn dir für eine Entscheidung in einer netzpolitischen Debatte?
Ja, ich glaube, ich wünsche mir vor allen Dingen, dass so Leute wie Tanja und
Thomas weitermachen können mit diesem Werteset, das sie heute vermittelt haben. Das wünsche ich mir.
Und woran möchtest du als nächstes gerne arbeiten?
Ja, das kann ich hier nicht offenlegen.
Bester Teaser aller Zeiten. Wir sind gespannt, auf welcher Folgennummer Chaos
Radio wir darüber sprechen werden, was Konstanz nicht sagen kann.
Wetten werden gerne entgegengenommen. Ansonsten bleibt mir nur noch eine Sache
zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Tschüss.